[Music]
you just showed up like you might need
some practice uh you going down for the
count it's going down tonight I do it
all for my family you do it all for the
likes I hear that Bell and I'm ready to
fight Turn Me Up Turn Me Up Turn Me Up
they want the boat they don't work and
no don't mess around end up hurting them
I say the wrong thing make it personal
you say the wrong thing I might hurt
them all yeah what is up fam we are back
Calabasas fight campaign for UFC 282.
hopefully you guys are recovering after
last night's bar stool and the rough and
rowdy companion with those boys much
different crew a little older it's gonna
be a little more calm down
what a little older a little older are
you the Youth of this are you the young
whippersnapper I'm the Young Buck let me
introduce the cast tonight to my left we
got my partner in crime the guy who
taught me everything I know it is Brian
the kid Cowan
and sent across for me he's the most
handsome man in Hollywood he is a legit
movie star he's coming off a fire movie
I watch it myself and you guys know I'm
a Gearhead the Lamborghini move is
fantastic it's Frank Grillo he can throw
a right hand it's better looking than
all of us and then directly across from
me is the man the myth the legend he is
a throwback comic from the 90s it is Hot
Tub Time Machine it is Sam Tripoli good
to be back better in the fighter seat
this is where all the heavyweights I put
you there because thank you you're
fighting yeah Sam two questions if you
were a fighter what would be your
nickname yeah uh and and what would be
your walkout my nickname would be the
monster and the monster is based on an
old joke where it's like the monster's
the guy that like bangs the fat chick so
you guys can all bang the the good
looking ones that's how we're starting
this okay so that's what I would do I
would bang the chick who holds the
purses while you guys get yourself going
no your name would be the grenade yeah
well I'm the guy who jumps on the
grenade jump on the ground I called it
the monster back in my day prank just
froze Frank's not ready for that this
old school comic talk by the way are we
gonna are you and I gonna play some bets
tonight yeah we will can we warm up
first before I start throwing on cash I
apologize Sam because it has to rhyme
with your nickname right like Sam the
tornado Tripoli oh there you go the
monster Tripoli doesn't work he calls me
the monster that's because you're a good
comedy okay yeah and I [ __ ] fat chicks
all right well okay coming in hot okay
we are we're not gonna win this YouTube
channel already oh is it tour oh yeah
it's too early ten minutes that's all
right we're live who cares it's my guy
Patty listen last night Rampage Jackson
talked about getting his ass eaten for
five hours saying how much he's against
it bro imagine being in that dumpster
wait wait wait oh my God is this is this
slang for getting beat up no no no no no
Frank welcome to oh this isn't a family
program no oh God no no nothing I do is
for the kids so five hours of reaming
and and he didn't like it no he he he
honestly hit
p-d-s-d-s-d STDs him and Teddy swims
talked about getting their uh booties
licked and he swims for an hour because
he's like I finally have a real
girlfriend and he's like oh by a woman
yeah he was like Yeah by a woman yeah
and he goes my roommate say I I need to
try it and I was like they're gay right
I figured out that your roommates are
gay he's so excited and then Rampage
hold on if you like getting your butt
eating your that means you're gay no I
mean no no no no don't be gay no it's by
the way who's looking to and I love uh
Rampage he's a dear friend Legend yeah
but who's looking at his backside going
oh I gotta have that got a real freak a
real freak on yeah that's the first star
people are out there yeah there are
people that have anal fixations and they
think it's something that happened to
them in fact now no hold on I didn't
bring that up to rehash get molested I
did it for two hours last night I was
molested oh no you know what this I'm
gonna have to you're gonna have to stop
you okay okay all right he brought it up
listen I was asking Frank because I
watched the Lamborghini movie you know
I'm a Gearhead I was like hey Frank do
they give you like a sweet Lamborghini
but no it doesn't work that way let me
in the cars on the movie yeah yeah you
know what came from that is that Eddie
Griffin used to have a TV show and they
had all of these he was shooting
something where they had all these
expensive cars and like Eddie Griffin
just decided to jump up on one of the
cars and just start running from car to
car to car on the roofs wrecking all the
cars yeah it's a very famous situation
that was like whooped his ass when he
got down oh dude it cost so much money
for a car guy that's like oh crap I
would go nuts you're a Gearhead no I
like car I wouldn't go I you know I
can't afford to be a Gearhead come Frank
Frank hey Frank hey Frank you're talking
to us hey yeah hey hey I know the
Hollywood humble is getting worse this
is a GQ Magazine you're not tricking
anybody seeing your new house yeah okay
and
you're fine
oh there's the Lamborghini look at that
now I wish they gave you that
Lamborghini bro that's a 1970 mura which
is deemed the most beautiful car in the
world it is in the Museum of Modern Art
really as the most beautiful car ever
made that color that color and then you
know the the backstory there is the
Lamborghini started the guy used to
Lambert used to work for a Ferrari no no
right no Lamborghini came out of the war
and he started he was a farmer and he
started a tractor company yes and he
made these amazing tractors and became a
very wealthy man subsequently bought
seven Ferraris one for each day of the
week and every time he would get in his
Ferraris the clutch and the brakes would
go and he'd have his mechanics at his
Lamborghini tractor Factory retrofit
from the tractors oh wow and they fit oh
wow and so he went to Ferrari to make a
deal with him like maybe we can do it
yeah
Ferrari who was played by Gabriel Byrne
great actor um he said go peasant make
your tractors you're a tractor maker you
put the chip on the shoulder it's like
okay here come here comes think about it
when you think about it Ferrari the
Genesis of Shelby and the Genesis of
Lamborghini was born out of Ferrari
correct because they they wanted to
compete with friends they hate them yeah
yeah and they did and by the way Shelby
beat Ferrari anything about Ferrari yeah
oh yeah I would love to play that
Forevers forward Fry versus Ford with
Matt Damon Damon and you know uh yeah
yeah what's uh Christian Bale but then
also you know uh Sean Shelby uh Sean
Shelby's the Matchmaker for the UFC but
Shelby Carroll Shelby Carol Shelby huge
roots in Venice he started an investing
oh yeah man oh wow yeah yeah really to
me Carol Shelby is the coolest of all of
that man he's like an American hero oh
yeah because for me I'd be like I'm
Ferrari you are my cars that's so fast
yeah no no dude Michael man is making
Ferrari right well he should hear this
he should my cars are red there they're
all fast
my car I said that big engine and they
have the wings
but if Michael man calls like hey you'll
get the Roll Just name three Ferraris
and it's yours right right just name
three friends
I can actually do it red spider
no spider's not one that's awesome
version of one yes
my favorite car I've ever driven is uh
my GT2 RS but
Ferrari's right I love Ferrari like I'm
the Ferrari club The Love foreign
I'm used but you pay hundreds of
thousand dollars over MSRP so I get them
at MSRP you get them them well you don't
got a couple Ferraris Ferrari yeah you
don't buy a foreign
we had the same Asian this is 20 years
ago for 10 minutes and I said I go with
the Frank's getting these rolls and my
age goes Brian Brian Brian you said that
three times
you're not Frank Grillo you'll never be
Frank Grillo and you're a completely
different casting than Franklin that's
like me being like but the rock got the
Rover no no we know Dwayne Johnson got
the world do you know you're not the
rock they never heard you're a Ferrari
no they never saw this you know what I
did when he said that I I actually cried
down I was on the phone I went okay yeah
you're right sometimes you need a
haircut hurt your feelings it's all
silly Hollywood's so black and white
it's all silly Holly wouldn't hurt your
feelings Hollywood's like professional
sports
it's worse because you know what it's
really personal like sports is a
meritocracy right so it's pretty cool
you didn't catch the ball you're not as
good as the guy who caught the ball it's
black I want a bad day be cool yeah but
in in Hollywood it's like well
well he's just better than you yeah why
but why yeah we both act yeah but what
is he doing symmetry right or or he's
connected some something along the lines
when he was 18. yeah well I couldn't
because my father was an alcoholic and I
had helped support the family yeah
should I watch what I want to say on
this I don't want to get anybody's
better ruined okay no
I have a series of jobs hey Rampage last
night finish an entire bottle of tiger
thick he did kept calling it thick tiger
hey man was he getting a rim job while
he was drinking he wishes he drank
enough where he wished he got one
brother you are you are the rock you are
like the rock I'm the alley cat version
of The Rock you are way poor version
you're the Brown version well no he's
kind of he's Browner he's brown and I am
I'm the I'm this I'm the skinny signed
this I did it's fantastic thanks brother
it's good whiskey right it is fantastic
very proud of you bro what makes one
whiskey better than the other a lot of
his preference love it's like like
that's 10-year age Japanese whiskey
mixed with American bourbon so it's the
first to Market so it's different than
all the other stuff stuff you see on the
show I think I love the job Japanese do
it the best yeah I better have some they
do everything the best
they're not having kids they've stopped
having kids yeah but Japanese are like
we're good that's true but they will
never ever make a variety
hey you can't you can't mess with the
Italians when it comes to certain things
yeah
she's great yeah she's great yeah well
Sam let's get right in how about that
trade worst trade one of them we're
straight oh dude we should have gotten
some pics
the death arms dealer yeah right Victor
boot yeah I mean how about that but to
be to be to be fair now this might have
been leaked through the white through
the White House to cover their ass they
said well we tried getting the the
Marine the the military veteran out but
they wanted to exchange and they went
compromised they want to exchange the
Marine veteran I think he's Marine
veteran for a straight Russian assassin
and we're like absolutely not they're
like okay is off the table right like
that's the only talk we're going to do
they're like how about you give us the
arm The Merchant of death for the WNBA
player
and America was like okay
is that is that how it went down yeah
that's what they're saying I don't trust
any of that and I love that everybody's
like oh my God we got back for just I
mean there's the the White House the
president and the vice president have
locked up more people for drugs than
anybody else I mean it's unbelievable
African-Americans too oh oh that's Kamil
Harrison for most yeah I mean if when
she was running they were going through
like she like hid evidence and would get
a guy off death row horrible and
everyone's like thank you why I was like
what are you talking about we have
people all people in jail for weed right
now should be released 100 percent
mushrooms are on the tail of weed like
yeah yeah oh yeah it's happening
too I micro dose sometimes before I go
box I love it yeah people love it uh you
know used to uh fighting Microsoft
hopefully I'm not in his business I
think he talked about a Rogan but uh Joe
Schilling world champion kickboxer you
should do shrooms because he felt like
you're on that scene Spider-Man was
doing punching you can just see it and
it's real slow I said shrooms to make
everything slow down while he's really
tired
he did that for a while well you know it
won't come up on your drug test you know
what comes up as mushrooms like food
poisoning oh interesting that's how you
can get away with it right I digress but
I was listening to Cerrone the other day
cowboy was talking about the liver King
that whole you had a mom oh no so Cowboy
came in here and I went oh you're on the
same stack the liver king size but he
says he goes I'm retired bro yeah but I
and but I'm admitting it yeah he goes
I'll be open about it and I go I go
Cowboy can you imagine fighting with
that in your system I go you'd be
undefeated he goes I'd never stop and
cowboy goes you know me I do you trained
like a madman already imagine being on
steroids and fighting Cowboy you'd be
world champion he told me he was 290
he's big he's jacked and then he goes
I'll connect you with the guy well I
guess I want to be jacked and he goes
are you gonna are you gonna do a shred
out bro come on
be bad for comedy yeah
I'm trying to get out of here we're
trying to watch Bryce Mitchell fight
this Bryce Mitchell oh okay now Bryce
Mitchell uh this guy Craig monster
monster correct me if I'm wrong chin
he's an underdog Bryce Mitchell he's on
a Sixth Street win a six little fun
fight Sammy uh uh Bryce Mitchell is a
flat earther yes I know you'd like
yeah he wanted to argue Rogan and that
what I said going into this fight is I
want Bryce Mitchell to win not that I
don't like this gentleman uh taporia not
that I don't like him but just because
uh Bryce Mitch went hard on the paint on
social media challenging Joe Rogan to
debate about Flat Earth I love that
that's hilarious so I can't wait so
there's this animosity so I like
awkwardness I want to see Bryce Mitchell
win and then drogen has to interview him
because that'd be the best because he'll
be on a high he'll be friendly he'll
just be like come on Joe have me on Joe
Black I'll have you on and then this can
be fantastic oh be great now now uh you
gotta coach him up though Sam do you
want to put some money on this fight
I'll take Bryce I'm not getting bad I
gotta bet with taporia okay you know
that yeah why now now this is Brian this
is Bryce's biggest challenge
and Bryce is a killer but this guy is a
hell of a striker his boxing's crazy
good and his wrestling's really good so
I'm very he's also a brown belt under
Dana here oh no I'm sorry that's uh I
want to start taking Juju no he's happy
I'm stupid
uh he fights with him below I think I
might be wrong so real quick Bryce is
the underdog he's uh minus 130. I'm
sorry plus 135 Ilyas minus one that
makes it okay rude for Bryce well no but
you're gonna take him so let's start
first card tonight so because I'm taking
the dog here how about if if Bryce wins
you owe me 800 if your guy wins I owe
you 500 okay I love Bryce though
he's a good looking kid too look at him
he's a stud I had uh I did a interview
with him and he did it from his farm and
the chickens behind him would not shut
the hell up chickens talk bro I love I
love this kid I love him but you're
voting against him yeah that's not
personal that's just what I'm that's
just kind of of what it is but I'll tell
you this kid is he's special man now now
is he an underdog in the debate against
Rogan too about Flat Earth he's probably
a plus yeah I mean if you're a plus
seven thousand argue that the Earth is
spinning around the Sun you're you're
always going to be the undertale oh
that's what I'm saying he's a plus seven
thousand I mean
there's this whole like theory that this
the stars all these plants revolve
around the Sun but the sun revolves
around the earth now and it's actually
makes sense on every different level now
now B he he fights his campus but you
know that they don't care the uh
heliocentric model was started by a
Jesuit you know that right no I didn't
know okay
so you know that right Sam Brian is it
Brian I know it's signed to Sam section
right now but I'll explain something to
you right now it it the heliocentric was
started by a Jesuit started by science
and the Vatican by mathematicians no bro
right yeah well Jesuits remember yes
they were yeah
yeah they were highly educated and
remained so okay remains Georgetown
University they've manned to win by uh
submission plus 500 that I'm a better
man that's not a terrible bet that's not
about if you want to make some money oh
I forgot to show you on this one yeah so
you know look but the other the other
thing you gotta remember Bryce has been
there were some pretty Heavy Hitters and
he did well against Barboza he all
struck Barbosa to get him down no that's
what makes him he's he's an X Factor
he's very special there's something he's
probably got that Farmer's strength you
know like they just throw like cattle
that Matt Hughes yeah exactly maybe I
don't think so and he's got hard nipples
so I mean that to me means something he
has got he has got he's a he's he's
fought some pretty good Strikers against
etson Barboza he outstruck him on the
feed he was okay Andre feelie Charles he
got the same reach
yeah
and by the way to Pro is not five seven
uh yeah I doubt it he has a he has the
same nose that I have that's cool really
that looks like maybe like if I opened
you he would be inside he looks like a
mini me right yeah it's like Russian
dollars yeah I didn't know Bryce was
that tall he's 5 10. and this is in
Vegas
uh this is in Vegas Rachel yeah this is
Vegas because Patty see there's a lot of
Patty the body support because uh last
time Patty fought in Vegas there was
really no crowd so this first like
T-Mobile outside of uh Liverpool I'm
sorry but the difference in bodies now
with usada compared to back in the day
so interesting to me oh nuts right I'm
absolutely nuts it's really interesting
we saw a really really pissed in
everybody's Cheerios it's not fun
anymore
I'm with you it's not funny some guys
just fell right off huh like radar
bummer
same with baseball like they're hitting
baseballs we want to see home runs let
them do all the voids they want what are
we doing here and you get and then the
MLB took all that money from those guys
being so exciting Sammy so Mark McGuire
chasing the home runs Barry Bonds yeah
all the TV right deals and they're like
yeah but you're out of the Hall of Fame
it's like oh but you let them do it and
then pass them now now you're upset
about it they made all the money off
their jerseys 70s and 80s they were
taking amphetamines the whole time
they're taking Greenies and they
squeaking their balls large Taylor was
snorting cocaine yeah yeah yeah
Ernie Lang said he was in rehab with
Lawrence Taylor Lawrence Taylor told him
he was never not high not one place
the greatest
you've been playing linebacker cracked
out of your mind well if you learn I've
never done changing the position I
haven't either changing I've never done
Coke but imagine trying to block
Lawrence Taylor this freak madman on
cocaine yeah
I've snorted guys on cocaine they do
spinning back fist 30 times
got to have like some kind of blackmail
on Dana White right that she's Brittany
the other one that's been there Ariana
Celeste she's just a staple of the of
the league
here we go here we go I'm gonna take uh
the sidekick 500 800 on this B right I'm
gonna take this this whole this whole
main card is fun oh
this guy's a very good boxer and he's
strong impressed on the kicks I just
throw on some Bryson he does need to get
him down if he's going to win this oh my
God that kick was hard yeah this this
guy's playing for keep this guy is no
little dudes get pissed
yeah little dudes have that little man
anger yeah
180
yeah that was a nice
Bright's gonna have to come down even if
he were to pull guard over he can
transition it happened I think Bryce is
going to try to stand and bang and
that's going to be ah no well because
even with Barboza he's fine on the feet
so he clipped in there a little bit he's
oh see he can't take too many of those
coming in no no this guy can
yeah Bryce being undefeated I thought
he's gonna get a big boy not that this
is a tough fight I'm not doing Bryce
there's still this one's gonna be a
bonfire
way to go daily 79.99 God you're too
good to us Uncle Dana thank you God
bless you Merry Christmas
did you get my card in the mail who's
saying that Theo he tries to make every
pay-per-view
he tries to make the tweets on every
single pay-per-view oh this boy's
Playing for Keeps it's hard too and he
has that nurse's tattoo on his back yeah
that's weird that's a nurse sign right
oh medicine you gotta be careful coming
in like that I'm sure there's a story
with it so I'm not making fun of them
Bryce can catch a shot boy he's
there's a chance it's just you know
excuse me 14. it just takes one oh and
also if you're Bryce Mitchell oh Jesus
what a badass Bryce is because he's like
number nine think about most guys
because the rankings what rankings do
you have that number next to your name
then they can when you you can turn down
fights now as UFC fighter when I was
trying it was not an option you get
fired if you're number nine and they go
hey one fight 14 like I'm not doing that
I'm gonna fight somebody in front of me
right but now and they don't hold it
against you
uh when I was fighting there was no
option now they they don't hold against
you back in my day I know I'm getting
older this fight is reminding me of
vulcanowski and t- City right now
interesting it is I mean it's just I
just I'm worried that Bryce is going to
take a lot of damage Superior doesn't
have the volume max but I feel you'd be
it's yeah you can only take so many
shots yeah I don't like that I don't
like it yeah but see that right hand
he's he's throwing his right hand off
it's not as bad as oh here we go this is
what we need baby now run to the cage
now let's go to work daddy let's go to
work daddy
yes Savage on the ground it's time to go
to work good work
that song boy is it hot in here is it
just this jacket it is hot oh boy oh
here we go get his back go transition
the back Daddy
wizard got him in a wizard sort of
these guys take down the fence is pretty
status it is he's good he's a good
wrestler it's also a lot of energy out
of uh Bryce yeah thug nasty
I changed my nickname to a flat Earth
Mitchell right yeah I would too bro Flat
Earth merch like the people that believe
in Flat Earth there's a lot of them
I don't know how you could believe in
flutters oh [ __ ] keep that hand up
please Bryce
keep the hand up welcome down my man my
man Eddie Bravo uh would say we know
more about Flat Earth than we do with
the ocean you know well there's more
evidence there's a lot of interesting
stuff uh well Eddie's I know Eddie Eddie
has his degree on
and I know that Bryce does to it okay so
here we go especially we've studied a
lot on uh it's such a [ __ ] am I right
yeah I mean I mean it was a big week
though he admitted that there's
conspiracies which is
where that Twitter dump is astonishing
it's astonishing it is oh that that's oh
yes there we go Bryce no no
[ __ ] nice top single leg though oh
here we go then he has a minute to work
now if he can slice through this like
butter I will I'll even double my bed B
I like it dude I like the weird I like
your confidence but I'll double the BET
right now
how much you bet I bet 500 if I win I
get 800 if Brian wants to gets 500
because I took the dog here everyone be
cool but I'm not gonna bet against Flat
Earth Mitchell
that'll be you finally uh admitted that
some conspiracies are true like JFK
right I can't fight you if you don't
think JFK yeah I haven't looked at me I
I do think what do you think the the
Kanye West stuff what do you mean like
all the stuff he said on Alex Jones
super interesting I I didn't I didn't I
didn't see any of it what happened
yeah I know like the the far rights like
we agree with him but he has a mask yeah
and it's from that one fashion company
that's getting a lot of [ __ ] right now
Santiago yeah
aggressive oh he did very aggressive
he's very interesting
yeah I think he's got major dude his mom
died his wife is taking his kids away
he's he broke thank God his wife Bryce
Mitchell just ended that round on top
that's why he doesn't mean he won the
round though
as much uh yeah notoriety is they should
but uh exactly like Strikers now right
they've manipulated it but also the
judging the uneducated so they don't
realize a lot still like we're 25 years
into this biggest problem in MMA and
Dana just goes don't leave it up to the
judges no I know but the guy I'm
fighting is pretty [ __ ] good yeah I'm
trying to get him out of there yeah just
so happens he worked trains I'm not
getting punched in the face yeah he's
hard to take out boom who do you guys
give the first round to
although
because even if you do get him down with
your detection you've got mini shop on
this one mini shop first round there
there may be a lot of this technique
works for Bryce so he's going to be
doing a lot more of this he's going to
throw twice and then and then that's
right that's Bryce's ammo yep one two no
we haven't seen in the UFC face tattoos
there's not a lot of Fighters with face
sugar has one that's it you think
there'd be way more does my boy Sean
Brady have one no you know what no Matt
parrot Mike Perry has one oh mine on the
UFC he's on the UFC
he's going to Russia and fighting
Russians in press conferences yes he's a
fun guy though
uh but Sam fill me in while we're
watching this what uh what was
interesting what Kanye said
he mentioned like the Hitler's
disability that this guy hates talking
about
kazarians it was really interesting now
Sam explain to me that gentleman that he
brought with him that guy who's like a
great like straight up weirdo right well
I mean it's a he's his campaign leader
yeah and he like refuses the Holocaust
and all that Fuentes yes yes he's denies
that the Holocaust yeah right he's 24
years old another I mean like dude it's
like you're 24 bro you know I just yeah
its intelligence versus smarts bro and
there were a lot of data dog but you
don't know his presentation you know
yeah
um um uh Dwight D Eisenhower said get
this on the record now get get all the
pictures and all this all the movies of
the Holocaust on the record because
years from now there'll be some jerk off
really who's gonna say it didn't happen
he called me I guess by the way yeah and
by the way um get it all on the record
get the films get the witnesses because
somewhere down the track of History some
bastard will get up and say that it
never happened Dwight D Eisenhower this
guy's great at looking stuff up [ __ ]
yeah chin but I'd be a little nervous
right now I don't think we can afford
Frank though
oh my God oh my God oh my God that
that's that and then Chris oh he has a
deep guilty ah Bryce can fight that he's
okay yeah he's okay here still though
it's trouble here Bryce is too tough for
his own [ __ ] good man well we don't
want what do we mean he only has 12.
get knocked out right there no see see I
like Bryce on the bottom because he's
such a good Grappler keep coming out
buddy you gotta uh the under hook [ __ ]
up damn it I'm too hot in this jacket uh
take it off put you on the jacket yeah
it is Toasty right you're okay in that
leather jacket off oh boy boy this isn't
good and now here you just gotta keep
wailing the ref goes get up get up he's
Landing he's hitting him yeah man he is
getting beat up it's a street fights he
really is
Jesus oh he oh he looked up this can
[ __ ] your career up man
no he's only 12 and Opie so you gotta
you gotta fight certain guys I know I
know can I say something now
Bryce is very talented he needs to be in
a different Camp he needs to be in a
house oh [ __ ] he's got to be in a
[ __ ] a camp-like American top team or
or AKA or something I'm sorry fighting
guys he needed his stomach needed a
chest yeah it's not this guy's a [ __ ]
monster well that's that's the thing the
times are different now too like the
number 12 guy would give the champ a run
for his money like these guys are so
talented yeah well-rounded do you feel
like female mma's like growing leaves oh
yeah like nuns oh tap them out
that's it I owe Brian five dollars
that's it five dollars that guy's just
too good I knew that was gonna happen he
looks just like me and I'm proud of him
yeah are you proud of your son oh yeah
that's my son God that was I had him
yeah he got that was uh that was that
was an ass whooping he beat him up I
hate seeing that
where is he from
well if he gets on the mic he's like
what's up Joe Rogan I'm with you the
Earth is round that's what I do there's
this round who's with me crowd's all
boom
boom he's from Spain
oh
yeah boom oh he's from Georgia from
Russia yeah
yeah there you go that's uh that's where
they grew up wrestling and doing the
same [ __ ]
so his wrestling his wrestling really
showed once he started
landing on the feet and then this
submission was sick the setup he locked
it in wall center of gravity yes yeah
just awful
well you're not gonna be a filthy setup
though filthy and dude to do that to the
number nine guy no he's gonna be top ten
that kid's a problem little brown
there's a problem
we renamed him we named him figurito
Moreno four Saturday January 21st oh boy
well hey man he's Gotta Move camps yeah
Moreno because his coach that's some
great that story is not what do you mean
I don't know the story what
I don't know oh my God what's it like
James krause's James Krauss was the head
coach James Krause was the head coach
but um and he was doing Insider batting
trading but listen don't do don't take
James krause's bets because if you're in
a bet you got to use DraftKings listen
this is called a Segway this is UFC 282
and if you want to bet on the rest of
the main card and watch the Cowboys
fight campaign with me and the boys and
make some Bank do it with DraftKings
sports book the official sports betting
partner of the UFC tonight new customers
can bet just five dollars pre-fight
money line on any fighter to win and get
150 in free bets if they do check this
out the dog's squealing right now kill
him right now everyone can earn up to 50
boost when you place the same game
parlay on UFC 282 so you can still bet
on Patty the Baddie uh Maga mad you can
still make Bank on this card you can
take the underdogs you got uh pots and
nebio still fighting you got Darren till
who's an underdog against duplessis you
got Patty Pima Underdog you got mug and
Med underdog so there's a well Magma's
the favorite but you know what I'm
saying take the dogs do the parlay make
some bank with DraftKings download the
app right now use promo code shop show
bet five dollars pre-fight money line on
any fighter win get 150 dollars in free
bets if they do that's code shop show
schab show this Saturday at draftking
Sportsbook the official sports Spring
partner of the UFC Frank Jones ABS is a
distraction minimum age eligibility
restrictions apply see show notes for
details Frank you're bad no what was
that you were what were you doing Frank
how are your how much I haven't seen
that before relax what are you talking
what do you do train every day probably
you don't take days off days off [ __ ]
ready Frank no days off gorillo that's
your fight moniker no carbs Grillo over
here man have a carb a little bit no
there's nobody more discipline I I told
you we were roommates for about four
months [ __ ] can sleep five hours
a night and he goes and trains for two
hours no matter what starting at about
oh bro when I was a UFC fight I was in
the middle of Camp Frank would train at
the same gym at boxingbird he was
trained hard on Iowa I was like bro I'm
fighting Travis Brown what are you
getting ready for it's true I make a
living doing this why how are you
beating me to the gym and then staying
longer than I am to get ready for work
he trains adjusting portion like every
[ __ ] every day with all of his
Fighters and I said by the way these 25
year old kids are a bunch of
they're even softer than one weekend but
we were talking about that last night
like me and Rampage and cowboy are
talking about it it's like that's just
it's a different time it's a different
time man
that's society in general when you hear
a fighter say I need a mental health day
there's a problem
I need a mental health station oh boy oh
boy look at the size of Pereira jacked
exactly
because they had the fighters Awards out
there so I bet all the fighters are
there all right I was supposed to oh I
was asked to do it you were supposed to
host it Chill song but I was again I had
to go to Toronto no I think it was
Thursday night yeah
did thick boy win any awards
you won um
um most hated no
um God damn I didn't win that
uh but Sammy back to you uh now Connie
got a lot of trouble because and because
he drew a swat sticker around the star
of David well that's excellent well
that's a problem from uh a religion that
but it goes the other way that's in
that's a that's a that's a it's from
it's from the real real religion which
believes we come from Aliens which made
Elon Musk a honorary member by the way
that's all facts it's a Hindus Act
but also
um kind of got in trouble because he did
the anti-semitic thing and then he said
Hitler had good traits no he said I love
that let me tell you something I spent a
month doing fight World in Israel okay
with some of the baddest human beings
I've ever met in my life and I want
Kanye to be dropped into Israel and I
want him to say those things to these
Israelis see what I have to say there is
no Holocaust and blah blah he won't make
it out alive they will they will they
will [ __ ] it's hard
well they'll change if he's open-minded
to it which I think he is I I think that
uh but also did you see the uh
but I did you see uh the thing that I
saw where he was talking about how this
was all planned he's like I'm the you
will never see this again I was able to
get out of all these contracts off a
single tweet I told y'all and then
dropped the thing and walks off
performance hard
he's going what is what is the thing
that no one can say
I'm going to say it he's always stronger
get out all these contracts and do all
my all my things listen what he said is
wrong people should have a real problem
with the government or Adidas or anybody
going in and taking somebody's money for
saying something you don't like yeah
because what you do is when you set
precedence for going after something you
don't like you open it up for them going
after people you like and that's just
the way it is when we saw what they did
with Alex Jones you could hate Alex
Jones but what we're seeing with these
Twitter files that sets precedence and
then they start getting rid of people
like government officials yeah that they
start getting ready because people at
Twitter don't like their politics yes
that's how they do it they get you to
agree that that's a little different
than what Kanye's doing yeah I mean his
is a little different I will disagree on
that because but the exact precedence
when they go after that he had business
deals with these companies he represents
if you represented me right if you're
representing me and you start saying
[ __ ] like that that's a violation object
you have a morality
[Laughter]
according to Kanye this could either be
true or false we have to look at he goes
Adidas went to his bank and said give us
that money and that's what my problem is
I don't know it's even no there's some
of that but to Sam's Point two to and
again I'm not defending Connie but
there's I'm a gruesome on some of it
because what Adidas did endgap is in
Balenciaga what they did is they signed
Kanye and then he designed those shoes
right and designed clothes for Gap and
then they went hey and didn't tell Kanye
we can actually do this on our own we
don't need to give him his his share
we'll start making knockoffs of this and
selling that and Kanye goes hold on I
didn't agree to that yeah and they're
they're making their value of their
business went through the roof they've
made more money than God and kind of
goes hold on that's my exact shoe that's
my exhaust exact slide that's my
creation that's my idea and they go
sorry man and the contract you didn't
say anything about that because I
thought we were Partners thinking we
argues no no you're not allowed to steal
my ideas they went sorry that's the game
he goes that mean you get that get out
of the contract that's exactly good luck
you're in for six more years he goes oh
yeah watch this and he goes on uh drink
Champs great podcast and he goes I can
say anti-semitic teams and Adidas won't
do [ __ ] knowing they will do [ __ ]
knowing he can get out of his contract
wow so it's all his Mastermind he went
about it the completely wrong way yeah
but he got out of the contract but back
to your point Sam if if you can say
something right you should be allowed to
say anything there has to be some line
when you represent a company because
like my guys who work for me I mean if
they did that wants to take their money
back there's legally if you're inciting
hate and and you're you're creating an
environment I understand what you're
saying and I respect that I mean my only
pushback to that is that when you you
look at the other way now there are
people going white people are all racist
white supremacy male toxicity and Not
only was that like allowed it was not
encouraging and rewarded yeah there's a
bias when we're learning that we're
learning that there's a there's an
extreme and blatant bias and we have a
problem with male suicide in this
country right and it has real
ramifications and we have a bunch of
guys who everyone makes fun of that's a
bunch of incels that don't feel like
they have a place in society
that's true so like we allow some that's
my biggest problem is like I hate all
generalities my girlfriend's Jewish I
live with a Jew like I don't like any
general generalities like that would you
want to be equal across the board like
If You're Gonna Cancel what I would like
is you call out somebody for them being
a psychopath scumbag loser and not going
oh it's their group that's that's what
we do and that so that's my problem 100
treat people as individuals yeah and if
somebody does some scumbag [ __ ] they you
should be able to call them out and not
use some kind of thing that as a shield
to Shield them from criticism man but
how funny is it blanciaga they put on
that weird Kitty porn campaign I mean it
was horrible then they put a ball but no
no repercussion they just issued an
apology and went that's fine because
they're in in the Hollywood Circle and
they're in they're protected but so they
do that and even Kim Kardashian comes
out goes listen I don't agree what they
did I talked to the owners they're gonna
do better it's like well hold on you
guys kicked Kanye off the island for
this yeah then Balenciaga because well
Connie was what he did was in a lot of
ways blatant and you can make sure you
could make the argument Balenciaga was I
think there's a big difference between a
teddy bear and bondage right and with
children by the way and by the way
remember
that Designer that Valencia agar deals
with and they have a lawsuit I believe
against him is a separate company
so what I'm saying is that there are
nuances in that ad that you can have a
problem with 100 but what I'm trying to
say is that when you say something like
I love Hitler or I'm going to go Defcon
3 on Jewish people so that is a direct
[ __ ] threat Dave Chappelle is funny
then he went to sleep yeah and then he
went to sleep
[ __ ] hilarious man I'm going to bed
yeah and I'm going to bed you know but
none of it's good but I I thought it was
good I think we have to know but you
have to know the difference but but you
also there is this is mentally ill right
everyone say oh he's mentally ill but
then when he does music oh he's a genius
right so there might be both it might be
dabble on both I think he's hurt I think
he got really hurt yeah and I think he's
been through over multiple times the
problem is he's lumping all I mean his
trainer is Shady that trainer guy Jimmy
started Sam that trainer do you see his
test have you ever looked at a guy named
uh Dr Jolly West have you ever looked
into that
and put him into the psych ward he text
Connie goes you keep this up you never
see your kids again I'm gonna put you in
Zombieland I'm put you in Zombieland you
never come back from
you
who works with all the Kardashians he
when Connie had his episode he was the
trainer this guy was the trainer for a
lot of people that have done horrible
things like the guy's track records
Jolly West
but uh yeah that's that's the guy that
if you look at all his clients he's it's
like it's like uh Charles man Charles
Manson The Jack Ruby Jack Ruby uh
Timothy McVeigh you're like uh Unabomber
yeah
all his clients
by the way because he was in he was on
that uh what was it the so you look at
Kanye West trainer and he's like Britney
um Murphy Brittany Murphy Jesus Britney
Spears everyone's going back Miller yes
he makes everybody go crazy yeah and and
you know Connie post who's like this one
I'm dealing with these are this is my
life Wow because he goes you keep this
up I'm gonna medicate you and you'll
you'll be in Zombieland you never let's
just talk about the big elephant in the
room what he went from two billion to
500 million a day I think that I feel
like true only 500 million how dare that
I know now by the way hey uh we got we
got Mike just AC went none today nobody
asked him I'm not that hot we got Darren
tell fighting uh Jack Armstrong
now Darren till hasn't got a win since
2019. he's been on a tough streak and
he's had some issues he's pulled out for
fights and uh doesn't look as strong
there but so he went back to his old
school ways so he went back to Thailand
to fight and train when he was fighting
Brazil instead of you know he left uh I
think Manchester but this uh du plessis
um no punk like this isn't a great flag
uh is that Pol is that Poland South
Africa that's right South Dakota he's
the ksw champion yeah he's actually he's
a world champion in other divisions yeah
he's buddies with Chris Van heerden he's
he Chris is there he's oh really yeah a
boxer no he's like the South African MMA
favorite he's good at everything and
he's been waiting for a big fight and so
for him this is his coming out party
tough night in the office
I just love that guy from South Africa
is fighting some British dude and I love
this I love it I love it I love it you
must love World Cup in the Olympics what
is dude that was crazy can I see you
watch any of that today
he's had a rough uh rut go he's lost his
last he's four out of five no he so he
lost four in a row yeah four out of five
oh man wow yeah so his last one was
Kelvin gaslin's Split Decision which
some people gave it to Kelvin but then
he's lost you know Woodley that's was in
Liverpool just too much too soon for him
miles Vidal that's when Mazda went on
that [ __ ] monster don't beat him huh
oh knocked him out in in uh KO in London
so you know he bursts on the scene right
he beat Donald beat Wonder Boy by
decision and the UFC went this next guy
and then they catapult him to the top he
wasn't ready for it yeah go to his
hometown Liverpool against Woodley and
then he gave him Mosby doll they didn't
take care of him then Kelvin gasum
Robert Whittaker Derek Brunson and they
ain't doing I don't know if somebody
they don't it doesn't look like Yoshi
doesn't like him there he doesn't look
like duplicities is no punk yeah this is
not a great fight for Dan tail there's a
reason why he's an underdog yeah till
doesn't look like he's in the kind of
shape he has been uh he's he's a Savage
training B he will be in jail yeah he he
is a straight Savage now do you want to
bet on this beat she hasn't been to the
beach I don't know enough about duplessy
but um I'll take duplessy I'm gonna take
until just because just because I I want
to I'm rooting for till I want him to
win because I think he struggles with
his mental health and he uses this one
he gets bad I'll bet one dollars no no
yeah oh no no you can't baby come on
dude don't want nothing double or
nothing I don't like double nothing
I don't like to look in Darren's eyes
and I don't like what's going on now God
damn I should have said this earlier now
he's just getting his ass up
dude I'm telling you police has been
begging for a big fight and they're like
here's Darren till like they this is not
a favor to Darren till doesn't look like
he wants to fight
yeah I mean It's gotta be hard man this
is a hard life huh oh Sam the toughest
yeah it's the toughest gig in the
world's about to lose right it's
miserable sir I'm sure that's why when I
bomb like Billy getting knocked out my
underwear in Brazil this can't get any
worse than this stand up
come on Darren now till uh he you know
he trains with uh hamzat and then he was
in Thailand I know but I don't he
doesn't look his body looked like he
wasn't training that much I said it'd be
on until you're off on that nobody
that's I never worry about during tail
being in shape or preparing for a fight
for him it's all mental yeah but then
when you miss mix the mental in with
duplicity's skill set it's a tough gig
for him dude pussy's better yeah he's
gonna he's gonna
he's going to punch himself Tyler oh you
think he's gonna get tired I think he is
at least there's not too much energy
here
you got a hand fight and turn into him
yeah you hand fight two on one baseball
bat you're gonna get punched in the face
but you're gonna get out stand up please
try but duplicities is heavy it's heavy
see you gotta eat some of those shots
and turn into them where is he yeah turn
into him oh my god oh [ __ ] oh that one
hurt that one oh my God
this is MTV Bully Beatdown style right I
mean he must have thrown 35 45 55. hit
me on this side that's what he said his
accuracy is pretty
and this is straight up World Star
Hip-Hop Beat Down Easy man turn into
them I just don't know there he goes two
on one and turn two on one turn two on
one turn turn turn oh but then you're
gonna take it off you do turn and
duplicity is a champion other divisions
in order I mean sorry other
organizations so he's a handful man
strong
couch
oh my God I mean this is he's just oh
for him all right now you're done yeah
it's so cool
MTV's bully beat down yeah the first
fight [ __ ] this fight and by the way
his brain is rattling yeah it's not good
you don't watch this for brain health
Frank
you know if you're worried about guys
oh yeah it's under the throat yeah just
not his night in the office that's not
you're not in the office now it's
terrible the UFC might cut him you lose
five out of six you're done keep getting
hurt he just doesn't look like he wants
to be there he's a star and they put
some power into him so he might get one
more they're not doing any favors though
oh this yeah that's nothing worse come
on if you survives this I'm gonna freak
out you almost want him to come on tap
to the choke if you're doing kill fan
this gets ugly I'm just tired now sure
is you got on the bottom no the guy in
the top yeah oh yeah figure four what's
up you know what the restricting his
breathing can't breathe yeah but but
he's alive I can't believe he got out of
that choke no he can't breathe you gotta
so that's cranking on them that's yeah
that's more of the Jaws that's going to
hurt the guy on the bottom mod is tired
of course uh I think the guy
but by the way right one minute one
minute's more tired and one has cough
stay there
you're a little less tired even if you
your heart rate's up your lowest tired
he got out of that figure when you're
winning Jesus turn in come on yeah come
on
go bro oh my god oh the gorilla oh oh oh
oh oh oh oh oh oh almost almost come on
too come on me he's tall oh he's tired
now you're right Sam Sam you [ __ ] saw
it Oh Sam you can see I want to see
someone guys you're tired
that neck is there till Darren grab that
neck
Darren oh he's going down
I think they're both tired no he is
awesome
take this Batman was that did I take two
can I use the bathroom my loud yes
how do you feel right now I mean if if
Tilden fire back they've been a 10-8
round but uh he did so it's 10. come on
oh my God he's breathing heavy though
he's breathing [ __ ] heavy I mean I'll
still bet you B but I do think till
might win this even though he got his
ass he's breathing heavy right now no
he's not you're in the middle of a fight
I know
he's breathing heavy from getting beat
up yeah he's all right he's not as bad
as I thought the other guy looked exotic
look he's looking over he's like is he
tired
oh how about Cowboy once the turkey got
hair transplant fantastic he looks
fantastic I'm going he said they paid
him 50k to go over their first class
ticket they hate him they paid him [ __ ]
we got to talk to we gotta get that
contact from Cowboy yeah we'll get you
you know 20 bucks but they'll do it and
I'm bringing you there and I'm getting
some of your hair
I think he lost his eye he had an issue
with his eye before
um I think his eye is gone I don't think
he has enough his eye looks awful he got
his eye plucked out that's Kung Fu
that's Kung Fu guys yeah
how tired is this gentleman let's see
it's just a big that was very strange
big strong Dutch guy look at him he
looks like I don't like his eye he looks
like um come on Darren schlock from from
Goonies no his eye looks like the guy
off uh Hannibal bring it up chin oh nice
nice oh yes
more fresh too come on
yep there's a lot of muscles and don't
throw those lazy Jabs yes come on Darren
Jill's gonna knock them out come on
Darren this dude is tired and I don't
like his tan yeah I don't like you he's
got a golden look he's cold though he's
cold it's more of a akiyama Tan's got
Till's got that uh that whales that
white whales look chin we bring up the
guy from the Hannibal he has the same
Isis guy from Hamilton oh oh come on I
know but show these guys come on Darren
he has the same eyes as the guy from
Hannibal he has faces
wow right there no no no no
one two one two the movie you don't back
up like that
it says Hannibal eyes I know the the
movie's called Hannibal but it's the bad
guy in Hannibal bad guy
come on Darren don't be nice
yes yes God damn it that's it that's him
you're so good perfect there you go B
you're so good at that it's a real time
oh oh my God such a terrible Talent by
the way by the way it's a very good
talent but by the way
head kicked yeah oh he's exhausted come
on Darren come on come on Jersey City
if Taylor's smart oh oh where is this
where is this
in Vegas get up dude yeah that's his
Vegas I knew that
please stand up do that old school he's
got he's got a shitty grip on the
wrestling thing it's not even a good
thing
oh the next there the neck oh my God
fellas
protected don't lose this fight please
don't lose this fight please don't lose
his fight after all this
come on
dude come on come on come on no he's too
tired he's too tired he's so tired this
is an exciting fight oh my God thank God
I didn't watch any World Cup I'm pissed
off oh you don't watch England lose God
damn it [ __ ] the quarter finds to
France no France is going to win the
whole thing Francis you think yeah
when is the final Ronaldo's got to drown
himself in top shelf [ __ ] now right
money he's just crying with hundred
dollar bills when is kid the
quarterfinals are next Wednesday or the
semi so next week so so that's the next
game uh yeah you have Argentina and you
have you have Morocco France nobody's
playing tomorrow nobody's fighting
tomorrow don't say fighting I mean oh
dude Argentina Argentina
who's left now is France Argentina
France Morocco uh Argentina
and Germany Croatia that's incredible so
it's gonna be Argentina versus uh France
dude look at this look at Darren till
he's gonna knock him out I think so he's
fresh he hasn't done one head kick but
Bubba he's got to work on his takedown
defense yeah
he works on his glutes too that ass is
flat yeah we got to talk to him he's
[ __ ] do you like your Fighters have a
nice ass yeah like a blonde ass I mean
it goes a strong ass is a strong body
yes
I like my mechanic with a blood ass
chefs everything why do women like men
with nice asses oh [ __ ] there's a right
one means you're healthy come on yeah
and it's just the flat house is
disgusting yeah I got a flat ass do you
mind that left a long time ago where
cause this squad look at the Kardashians
no you're not lifting weights though Sam
even if he did I wish asses are hard
that's hard bro damn it get a beer get a
BBL sprawl [ __ ] sprawl
hey Brian would you judge Sam if you've
got a BBL what's a BBL it didn't play
Brazilian butt lift Brazil I dude I hate
those no we'll take the fat from your
tummy Putt in your ass you look fine
dude yeah but what about these strippers
with like ninja turtle shells on their
asses pretty cool right no no yeah it's
stupid
um I don't like this but I think it's
all right
uh no that's not good if you're doing
till fan because you give the first
round let's give this round to Darin
even though he got him well he got him
down twice so didn't he yeah he did it's
gonna be tough
for sure no I don't get what Darren is
doing here he's tired he's getting beat
up I know but you can't let him get that
[ __ ] that single leg okay he's
grabbing his ankle and [ __ ] I don't
think he's got a choice the guy's pretty
good oh leglock Central 10 seconds so
he's gonna let him twist it off though
you got a Twist and kick he needs to
kick out he needs to kick out on that
back
for
two oh yo that's tight that might do
some damage to Till's front leg lead leg
there
let's see ah no he's all right yeah he's
they're both tired till looks less tired
[ __ ] this hey real quick uh we should do
this on Instagram too who has a better
chest Darren till or Brian count
both Flats
I don't know if they have inclines I
might have a little bit better it's just
up here Daddy that's what bothers me
it's like a bird it's like a bird yeah
but I need well down here is all right
but up here I'm packing some shoulders
you got to do your shoulders men need
shoulders yeah I need shoulders do you
teach it man I teach shoulders you do no
you would love to take your workshops
you look better in clothes when you have
your shoulders yes it's not my genetics
though guys yes it is
shoulders
see this takedown you and Brian are
built like Muppet Babies
[Music]
Muppet Babies
it's a muppet that's a baby what what's
on his stomach that's disturbing I might
be staff
looks like staff to me or he's shaved
and it's ingrown here oh it's a hell of
a fight or it's steroids uh no
come on boys let's go see you're built
like Gonzo there me yeah
you nailed that yeah that's my bill and
you look like him yeah for sure that's
me
that's your stage name too the Gonzo
Tripoli so I call my next special that I
was gonna call it weirdo maybe I should
call it yeah boy there's a liver opening
on on this guy if
his hands are up here yeah I think
that's fair oh whoever wins this round
wins the fight we're a great fight oh
nice I'll tell you right now whoever
loses nobody's getting caught no one's
getting cut here this fight's too good
for them
oh great
um I think the talent UFC is way better
than Bellator neither one of these guys
wants para but it's very close now some
of the Champions can compete but the
what makes the UFC you know the the NFL
of mixed martial arts even the team won
the depth yeah the depth is like one
through 50 in every division is you know
the killers do it's a nightmare
look at that look at that uppercut
but this guy can take a shot he's
getting punched in the face and he's
like it's his job right yeah
but Till's eye the other one's good not
good yeah
enjoy your victories one eye yeah
yeah it's a guys the other guy doesn't
look like he has any damage he's rugged
yeah he doesn't
like again his tan bothers me oh the
Jabs Landing for him he can't move
straight back
what sums up with Till's lights Anthem
one yeah and it's a strange thing Bubba
yeah I don't get a lot of this guy
looked like a world champion first round
uh Jersey show or a bro right late night
buy some time there we go just adjust to
just
can I reach my hand in there and play
with it
say you pushed it let me do some sock
puppets inside my
[ __ ] I need five minutes to diddle
myself come on Darren
yeah no till engine cut no matter what
happens here
but he's winning this round so far yeah
yeah
I think I think it's 1-1 this fight this
round determines the fight
I don't get this though got it what a
difference of shows last night we
watched rough and rowdy I watched two
small people go at it yeah oh the uh
rough and Riley Barstool two tiny people
tiny people just going at it how was it
fantastic but it's just you know now
were they at all proportional oh yeah
one was one had a long uh midsection a
little bit like a baby T-Rex
and then arms like T-Rex and I know
they're probably hung like [ __ ]
well they're women but yeah I don't know
[Laughter]
oh boy this is not always end up that's
bad it's bad oh no
pay me bro
pay me Brian
[Music]
oh come on Darren I know it's a bummer
for tail man what the [ __ ] that was a
that was a dog fight but get on till man
after bouncing back for that that first
round I know but it just yeah that's the
card at the breakdown last night fellas
and it was four hours of Mayhem I don't
care it's chaos pure chaos holy
holy twenty something that was the
strange it started at four weeks watch
this Victory you get taken down right
away and straight to Mouse
you see the two small people Sam you
have raging versus switch the doormat
now what those were dudes you said they
were chicks well the one guy's taking a
selfie but uh keep scrolling down 10
there's chicks there's small people
chicks there it is uh nope that's Vicky
one shot oh there it is Savage Sadie she
was 90 pounds four seven beautiful Bobby
Joe she was beautiful she's four four 95
pounds is that technically tiny person
under 411 we looked it up under 411
you're considered a small person really
it's frowned to say [ __ ]
I don't want to get anyone in trouble so
I didn't say it I know that's that's why
I said it so you know I wanted you yep I
could feel it I could feel that you
wanted to say it so I said it before
thank you honors.com CFC anna.com CFC
that's crazy chin you act like you want
the best supplements in the world that
guy wouldn't have staff on his upper AB
if he was on on it supplements if you go
to onnit.com CFC save 10 off the best
supplements on the planet and the best
nootropic on the planet they sold over 1
million bottles you save 10 off Alpha
Brain that's right if you've never heard
of Alpha Brain on its social positive
Alpha Brain will work for you you get
your money back if it doesn't work no
refund necessary no I'm sorry no uh you
don't have to send anything back you can
keep the bottle but you're gonna love it
so don't worry about it you save 10 off
all the workout gear kettlebells steel
Club maces streaming Fitness protein
powders Warrior bars and Alpha Brain go
to onnit.com
CFC for tempting off the entire website
you're welcome great holiday gift too
you know well
absolutely so after after a fight like
this right yeah
you just won are you just in pain Brian
take it from here you know what your
adrenaline is spiked yes but when you
get back to the locker room it just
stops it's weird because you're like oh
I feel good man you like I'll have cash
like I remember I thought Kroger nose
broke 19 stitches here I'm like I feel
pretty good and all of a sudden goes
so even after I want to be throwing up
like the paint's so intense yeah I
remember uh Gonzaga like kicked me so
many times like that's not bad but my
leg was swollen and then I woke up
middle of night and I was like oh my God
I couldn't walk oh so like during the
fight you're in fight mode so adrenaline
by the way gonzago is the you can make
the argument he might have been the
hardest kicker to ever like leg kicker
to ever step into the Octagon yeah I
mean and Pedro's up you can get a blood
clot from that [ __ ] oh yeah Hey Joe uh
hiso yes patriotism I win I went and
trained with him in Brazil yeah stud
yeah he he he like hit guys so hard he
was he was and by the way amazing guy
and uh in fact I met Regis progress was
down there teaching his guys striking oh
did you ever see his that's when he did
that yeah I saw I thought it was a great
show great show I like when he went to
Mexico yeah I didn't they didn't show
the Brazil episode because Marco Santos
the guy who we were following uh beaten
almost killed his wife that's frowned
upon yeah yeah
that's not sure there's a good episode
though do a bonus one yeah Extended Cut
dark extended he just yeah that's not
good
where'd you go Frank you went Brazil
didn't you went to Russia no I went to
Brazil Mexico Israel Myanmar Burma for
letway uh Thailand and where else did I
go one more place Africa yeah oh when
you had the best place it was the best
athletes right they're free times did
you jerk off to that episode These Guys
God loves those Five Guys
oh my God I just like he gets this weird
kind of glaze over his eyes when he
looks at those bodies so cause I'm gay
yeah but but they're all they're all
they're they're the best athletes like
of the people that you I mean for that
sport I mean for the they're just
amazing specimens I don't know that the
best guys did you guys uh radius martial
arts let's take showers after often you
saw the big panther Tales
what do you think is the best martial
arts if there is a best martial arts but
I usually what for make for this yeah or
for life for life because when you go
and train the real Krav Maga not the
Krav Maga that's in Beverly Hills but
the real Krav Maga it's pretty
spectacular what you can do they're
using like bottles anything anything
anything to kill a match literally like
they're they're in war all the time no
they're in tunnels yeah Israelis are
perpetually they took me down to the by
the where the tunnels were tunnels did
you see this guy this Delta Force guy
his name is Kyle I can't remember his
last name so I think it was in Molly did
you see this [ __ ] dude he just got
out so there's he's he's in Africa on
this shitty assignment he's like [ __ ]
this [ __ ] I gotta listen to the
podcast well
um the CIA station Steve he gets a call
like they they've taken over this hotel
these Boko Haram guys or whatever taken
over the hotel they got hostages and
everything else and he goes well well he
goes can go check on our CIA station
TV's next door to you to make sure he's
safe so he goes over there and the guy's
on the phone he goes what are you doing
he goes I'm on the phone right now he
goes well they've taken to the hotel he
goes I'm on the phone with the hotel and
he goes well where's the hotel and he
goes what and he goes give me the hotel
give me the hotel give me the numbers
the room numbers of all the people that
are under you know Siege right now and
he goes what are you gonna do and he
goes oh I'm gonna go over there and he
goes but it's only you and he goes yeah
that's fine just tell me what the [ __ ]
he gets his rifle his pistol whatever
stuff he goes into that hotel and killed
all the terror every one of the
terrorists and and saved everything by
himself shot them all
just [ __ ] like oh I can do this is
this it it should be yeah we can't play
it again
this [ __ ] is telling some story
of terrorism yeah I'm trying to remember
a human blow-up doll yeah it's fantastic
you missed it choked then the show
Justin Gates he's girl Jesus right so so
that's she's like she's like so I met I
met Gordon Ryan's girl Sunny she's
gorgeous yes and [ __ ] Jacks yeah oh
my God I look there I go what did you
just said on TV yes
he reached out to me and he goes hey
brother uh
um I'm thinking maybe we should roll
together I'm like what with George
Gordon Ryan yeah I'm giving you an open
invite to come down roll hang out fun
experience I'm like you know bro I feel
the best I just come to your fight when
he fights fighting Pena in the OC so I'm
gonna go watch yeah I'll just watch it
that there's something of him uh I
either wrestling or doing Jiu Jitsu
against Beau Nichols Yeah the rules were
set up for Bo nickel to lose that I know
why Bo nickel took that fight but
because he wants to get on the best
right I mean yeah but it was it was like
the rules were weird it wasn't set up
for success for a bow nickel oh you
think Beau Nichols can go on a run oh
yeah he'll be Champion 100 at 205 or 185
185 he'll be champ nobody's given
Pereira any respect bro elbow nickel
with Molly [ __ ] here I know but but I
just think this guy is special look at
these guys yeah but the problem is Bo
Nichols wrestling with the minute he
gets close to you he's gonna put you on
your back at will and he's going to
punch you in Beau Nico's supposed to
fight tonight he's also obsessed with
Jiu Jitsu right now what happened
he got injured but nothing major I think
they're gonna put him on a January
February card but he's on that January
when they're shown right now
did they announce when they the
which one they say if he's with his next
fight
it's hard to find them opponents too oh
really nobody wants to fight him no
because he you know he's a top 10 talent
but these two UFC's not getting toss my
top 15.
this guy came right out of the job tiny
little killers tiny Killers tiny camera
that sounds nice wonderful toy line
oh so it probably the same opponent but
later
not not the best pay-per-view yeah
I'll pay for it though
there's not a lot of the Old Guard left
no the new gun Robbie Lawler Shogun
Bobby's supposed to fight tonight he got
hurt yeah guard Gilbert Burns I think is
part of the Old Guard at this point 100
right yeah really yeah the old guy the
old guy's just kind of out yeah so this
must be Robbie Lawler and uh ponson
nebio and then Robbie got hurt so they
put in Alex Moreno
hmm Alex Marion was like whatever dog
yeah sure I don't think but Beau Nichols
doesn't want any part of Gordon Ryan and
Jiu Jitsu no no no no no I don't think
anybody really does no who does I don't
know what struck me about Gordon Ryan
was how big he was I didn't know how
tall he was oh not just tall he's Savage
Savage yeah he's how tall is he he's six
three four six three oh really super
freak super I mean best is he the Grace
ever do it yes he's up there yeah for
sure and and especially in the New Age
Jiu Jitsu you know his girlfriend
because Roger is probably the greatest
have you seen this 16 year old that
Eddie Bravo's got he's uh with the long
hair and he's heel hooking everybody but
he's been taking Jiu Jitsu since he was
six years old that's how it goes now
yeah right and he's nogi right yeah yeah
and just nogi yeah there's a thousand
ways to get you here look at his ears
not his like to do that yeah his aren't
great pontinobios are insane
so hopefully show one more time yeah
it's not a good time I was so looking
forward to Robbie Lawler ponsonibio
first rule of Fight Club you don't bet
against Robbie Lawler unless you're a
communist yeah I love him oh who doesn't
Robbie Lawler Robbie but he's like part
of that old school UFC like that was
like he's fighting back when Randy
Couture was fighting against chuckled
Dallas who's on Kingdom Robin was on
there yeah he's one of the old school
Matt Hughes boys yeah he's like old
school bro
companion me and Pat talked uh with the
Dana White uh drama because he was
talking about Pat but I got lumped into
it and then just I made a joke and it
got taken out of context it's social
media but Pat milchix was the really the
one doubling down on it you know then
Pat reached out to me but at the time I
didn't see it at the time but I'd have
Pat on yeah Pat got in trouble and he
lost his commentating gig because he was
in DC when they stormed the capital I
don't think he was doing storm the
capital that's so cute oh look at that
she's great oh wait you don't think it
happened not that I mean it happened not
to the level yeah but they did storms
Sam that's that's the person right there
right oh yeah this kid yeah he's been
taking it since and heel hooks everybody
that kid with the long hair a big the
big boy the thick boy yeah [ __ ] hell
yeah 16. thick boy might need to sponsor
him how about some guy last night uh
Ruff and Riley put thick boy on the
shorts I didn't ask him to is that true
yeah he lost though it doesn't matter I
love it yeah so Brown uh maskscape.com
CFC okay boy these guys are smooth
thanks to manscaped all right tis the
season clean the balls follow our
friends at manscaped are helping you
clear your driveway for safe travel this
holiday season Frank from stocking
stuffers to white elephants manscapes
products are top of everyone's wish list
for all the Bros even your hairy grandma
get her manscape my Defender just call
it something else he had some crop mops
for your pops or the body buffer for the
holiday lover win this year's white
elephant gift and help all the men in
your life go from the eggnog to the nice
hog this December safe 20 off and free
shipping by going to manscape.com CFC
e get that lawnmower 4.0 baby it's the
best in the world the all sorts of stuff
they get the shears 2.0 clip those
Raptor towns that you got on your feet
they got The Preserve cologne they got a
body buffer they got it all make holiday
shopping so much easier by giving the
men in your life or your thick Grandma a
Little Help from manscape Save 20 off
and free shipping by going to
manscape.com CFC that's right twimp
stuff and free shipping by going to
manscape.com CFC manscape for a perfect
gift that will be the holiday's biggest
hit manscaped Frank how do you keep so
smooth
uh I I manscape jeez is that the talent
in your chests are just like that I
don't have a lot of hair I'm not a hairy
guy you can't grow a beard man if I was
gay clean your nuts you shave down your
neck I do I do I do I do uh keep them
smooth yeah yes okay I do because I'm
single respect and you're shredded I am
shredded it'd be weird to be shredded
and just have a jungle down there tomato
pack yeah it would be very liver King as
a jungle down there he doesn't yeah but
that makes sense too
did you watch liver King on schultzy's
show no why it's just interesting you
you if you if you're if you weren't a
fan of Liberty you can watch that and he
was very humble and just like I [ __ ]
up I take ownership yeah but I wasn't
surprised that's no like I was watching
Rogan and it like Rogan said wait a
minute well are we surprised yeah
I didn't think it was gonna make the
news like when they told me like oh like
everyone was texting me you see your boy
liver King steroids I'm like of course
yeah like when he came on our show fans
like can't believe you didn't ask if
he's on steroes I'm like
because obvious yeah it's like bringing
the rock chicken steroids that's like
bringing Dwayne Johnson and being like
are you on steroids I mean yeah
I don't care yeah I don't understand why
I lift weights really hard to look like
that yeah
Rogan talking about this about the rock
on his thing is kind of created this
weird thing well Romeo's The Rock needs
to cut bro if you watch in context he's
joking he's like I demand The Rock come
out and give us the truth like choking
yeah he's a comic you [ __ ] yes yeah but
also like who cares I don't like why do
we yeah his friend called me up I was
like hey dude we're looking for a big
juicy guy to play this jungle bodyguard
whatever that is so weird
this is so weird that you're bringing
this because you were gonna ask you're
about to offer him apart and I'm gonna
throw you this anavar I just want you to
drink it
take it I put that needle so fast in my
ass
uh oh here we go here we go here we just
go around the security pontoon of you
yeah strange he doesn't find a hot
second he's a uh he actually does the
he does another language he's the
commentator another one I think it's
Spanish yeah he's really good at it too
yeah
36 getting up there now Alex morono
looks as though he hasn't been there's a
body like he looks like a sandwich
no he has a body like my Uncle George
yeah he looks like he works at Subway
and he's a Sandwich Artist yeah he makes
the meanest meatball sub yeah he's not a
badass but he does he does look like a
guy who yeah but you can't tell a
fighter by his no for sure
I agree oh faders
built like a freaking lunch lady another
guy he's not it's not you know you would
never think he's that tough well it's
fader to uh do what kind of martial arts
Kempo [ __ ] [ __ ] you know do you like
[ __ ] yeah yeah there's some great
people can Ensemble but Fedor has one
more fight against uh uh Ryan yeah you
know did Samba guy named khabib
nurmagomedov could I start [ __ ] at 50.
hell yeah dude you don't know Krav Maga
I'm taking Krav Maga you are but I want
you to do [ __ ] or Jujitsu just to study
don't do Jiu Jitsu I haven't started it
I did it but I go on tour with Eddie so
I just wear his mask you and Eddie were
doing some big venues too yeah well it's
pretty cool proud of you guys man I love
it he's the best oh I love him he's just
he's like he gets down this pre-flight
thing and he's every day every show he's
adjusting it like just stick to the
class before it goes up
I try to tell him to go open up with
this yeah know what works dude you're
allowed to fight with a shirt no
absolutely not well only females are
that's too bad it's well you'd want him
with a shirt on my problem with that
would be better and I see where your
head's at Frank and I kind of agree with
you so rude it's rude but also there's
truth to that box how many fights is
has a ton he was on a huge win streak
then he got injured it's been tough path
for him but um back to the shirt thing
the problem with that Frank is uh the
fact in the pool in the summer there was
a shirt it just draws more attention
you're right oh how is he letting that
just go without the shirt let them tits
fly down right do the Cannonball be the
fat guy you know what now that you use
the now be the lizzo of the YMCA summer
camp you feel me I feel you man I feel
exactly what you own it dude I like big
chicks do you yeah well you don't think
you do I think you say that because
you're afraid you can't get smaller ones
wait look look into Sam's eyes and try
to help be honest and say I wish I could
get better girls yeah but I'm gonna tell
you I like fat girls
I'm from upstate New York there's
nothing but thick [ __ ] are you guys
from the same area no I'm from outside
that's way Upstate yeah no but this
other thing about Sam too he likes girls
who are cross-eyed again dude I do like
cross-eyed with big teeth you like big
teeth big teeth close your mouth cross
side big teeth and out of shape you're
going after where are you ever gonna
find this girl after the crippled prey
yeah I get it it's a self-esteem issue
isn't it Frank I think it is what do you
think man I'm with Frank on this hey you
guys are coming down on you guys are all
well because she's a handsome guy he
doesn't need to think thank you talented
guy too you can do better not that one
no that's why I like all those girls by
the way he's shocking me oh yeah um see
you never tell them
you just never know right I mean he
throws punches with his chin up oh no
he's exciting too yeah he'll make it a
dog fight pontino he was on I think of
like a six fight one streak and then
just got hurt and it was bad for him how
is he taking overhand swooping rights
like that there's Montenegro so he was
there we go he's on one two three four
five six seven oh my CT my ass I was
right seven they lost our boy leech Lee
jingling
another one and then lost two of them
lost to the guy from China yeah
is leech uh is leech Chinese yes yeah
thank you I've been there how was that
Frank I never want to go there not great
you never want to go China not never
it's awesome well they've treated Frank
like a okay no pranks Tom Cruise
I was in Beijing and Shanghai but they
treated me wonderfully but I just don't
I don't like the way they treat others
their own people yes
back because uh
I don't want them to hear that and then
you don't get overseas distribution
I don't get Chinese distribution nor
does anyone else in this country yeah
they don't they only accept 12 U.S
movies a year is that true I'm not in
any movies that are going is that true
Brian hey hey Frank I'll tell you from
there hey Bree yeah you're not an action
star right nah you got something right
here do it the whole time I have no just
now well just the night there you go
oh you've been there Sam yeah I've done
stand up out there why because it was
fun it was a good time I'm no fan of the
Chinese Communist Party good time right
good times they were great the Chinese
people are amazing well um how long were
you you shot that movie wolf Warrior
there right yeah I was there for about a
month and a half didn't that movie make
a shitload of money a billion dollars
wow it's the largest it's the by far the
highest grossing domestic Chinese film
Jesus and it'll never be broken he
played he played wolf Warrior no I
played Big Daddy I mean Big Daddy
I remember that you were like [ __ ]
Brad Pitt for a while you still were you
in a nice hotel out there Frank oh I
lived in the nicest for the nicest uh
was it a Ritz-Carlton
yeah it was nice guy stayed in a [ __ ]
Castle dude when he did bodyguard too he
stuffed his face they did bodyguard too
uh who filled in for Whitney Houston
The hitman's Bodyguard Hitman hitman's
bodyguard too right Leslie Jones one
with Ryan Reynolds didn't you didn't you
accidentally hit Ryan
yeah I did punch him in the face Ryan
Reynolds yeah
oh [ __ ] how was that on accident though
huh
oh oh he got him oh my God this is not
supposed to happen man uh murano's a
Savage dude oh my God he's Young and
Crazy he looks like an extra from uh
he's not tired
supposed to happen to him
punch news just hasn't been active
that's the problem
look at you who's that the director
who's that guy with the hat who's the
guy with the blonde wig who's the guy in
the middle there he's drinking that boy
from Barstool
oh yeah there they are okay Frank in
that picture there that's the movie star
oh that's wujing and that is the scam
Hargraves Sam
Hardy's double in Warrior I know Sam I
know Sam then Sam became the stunt man I
we work together on on Captain America
both two and three and then Sam directed
he became a director and he directed
extraction with uh with uh he did too
bad he's not handsome as [ __ ] he's great
guys
yeah everyone's list for direct he's a
superstar I love it he's the next big
thing huh I love the director is he
directed extraction that guy's an actor
and a dress no no he was a stunt man
stunt man he's a stud look at him Mary
is directing Hemsworth right God he's
gonna be directing tits into his mouth
God he looks fantastic oh no he's a stud
yeah
but he loves fat chicks no he doesn't oh
look at that beer not his thing Sam you
wish and he plays more for me
guitar and he's a great singer like oh
so this guy's like the Jamie Foxx and
he's a killer why don't you marry him
Frank watch marry him
these wrecked Atomic blonde too no
Sam hargrave's good for him man I like
Toronto's win this fight aren't you
oh he's easily winning right yeah guys
only the first round
it feels like we're in quicksand he's
got his number now I never would have
called that for Sam I thought it was
gonna be a stunt man but he just gotta
know he was a stunt coordinator I mean
he basically directed wolf Warrior too
God with that face though you want him
on front of the camera he's not behind
him well he he was Hugh Jackman's long
time Sun Devil I remember because he
looked a lot like him Hugh Jackman in
Wolverine on Maddie all Natty yeah well
Sam is Sam's just I don't know you
believe that Ah that's what he says I
don't believe I think he was all Natty
in there
are some more dates more plates or
whatever more dates hey Jim bring up uh
Hugh Jackman The Wolverine
all Natty
I'll be able to tell you if he's already
he's the nicest person you've ever met
Hugh Jackman Jackman yes with Gavin
O'Connor I had Thanksgiving dinner he
was supposed to do Pride and Glory with
us well do you remember when we were all
well can I finish my story yes yes thank
you thank you look at that now Delia's
not here but oops
now that's not an added go down go down
no the other way go the other
one this one works
there's a little there's a little
something there oh hey for sure I was
um making a that guy's on every
supplement yeah
I thought you guys were gonna be it's
all good yeah
it's fantastic I mean I would if you
want me to be Wolverine I'm gonna look
yeah boss level I did some stuff
yeah it's Hollywood maybe jacked I was
Jack you don't think Will Smith did for
Ali everybody does why wouldn't it the
movie oh yeah you don't think Captain
America is doing freaking what's the
biggest concern Doctors Care I mean come
on that's not yeah I don't understand
why people are like getting weird about
it
well I just the influence of it yeah
look at that I mean you're you're
obviously look at the look at the
vascularity
look at them before
and keep naming steroids Frank that's so
many this dude you don't get like that
just off of anavares his face he's
probably on a Clean Diet oh my God he
had tits before
yeah come on man looks way better
it looks fantastic
why not why not if you're gonna be a
Marvel superhero why not I say I guess
with liver King he got in trouble
because he was denied it and going
against people who were on it well he
was doing something that represented a
certain lifestyle that kind of
went against saying the ancestral
tenants will get you yeah so but but
then a sister I don't think he said that
yeah but the ancestors
did he say that really I don't think he
was like if you do this you're going to
look like I don't think I said that uh
he I don't think he ever did I don't
think but I do think we got to give him
a little credit because then Cicero
living is healthy like if you're going
to live that lifestyle it's good you
know he's just on a bunch of sauce he
also lives he actually what I he does
live that lifestyle to an extent to a
large extent on Schultz's thing Schultz
goes what's the worst part about you
know you getting found out like this you
guys I have to tell my kids and I set
them down and I thought how stupid are
your kids
well they're not stupid they don't you
know what I'm saying though if you're
like what Dad did you lied to us if my
kids are like yeah we know dude wait you
see I see shooting needles in there we
assumed it was him I don't think he's a
bad guy no no he's not bad guy at all
around marketer he came up with a
character but he did say on schultzy's
show too that he's gonna go all Natty
he is he's getting off the stuff why
I don't know probably not great I
thought too I don't think it's that good
for you I don't know how long you can
sustain that kind of [ __ ] but those
levels of it supposedly he was spending
7 500 or 10 11 G's on just HGH when
she's overpaying and by the way you're
taking a lot of HGH which which is
HH just doesn't sing out your muscles it
enlarges like your organs your heart so
that's why if Olympia you see the power
gut because your organs are growing and
pushing out it's not healthy no it's not
oh
yeah but my question is
are there any biological shortcuts like
anything you put in your body is going
to eventually come up to something right
will eventually cost you I think that's
fair to say there's a price for
everything but but I think an effect but
I think too with uh liver King you know
he says and get off everything I want to
get off testosterone replacement because
let's say there's this taboo you know
talk about testosterone replacement a
few of the doc and low on vitamin C
they're going to say take more vitamin C
if you're low on testosterone I'm going
to say take more testosterone it's not
still that trt affect your sex drive
will it make you like an insane person
it'll make a little bit more it might
kill us when you're young the right way
though right yeah it'll make you not not
as fertile yeah it would ruin your sperm
count yeah that did it to me and then
also but if you're me it's a good thing
yeah my wing my wiener it bro no my
wiener didn't work on it it just stopped
working
I wish my weiner stopped working yeah it
was a blessing and a curse I really did
chin but you've you've done some trt
right you're still on it right now yeah
it works but sometimes there are there
are a lot of complications yeah it's
kind of crazy yeah yeah the direction
you mean yes because it's hard to keep
it there's something about with like the
estrogen and testosterone when you
increase your synthetic testosterone
level something happens with your
estrogen level and it kind of yeah
you're taking the uh the estrogen pills
too yeah I don't take it the way I
should oh you gotta stay on that yeah
there you go you don't want wiener
problems you got to take this but that's
what I didn't do and then them not
shrive up like pearls oh your nuts are
gone yeah nuts are embarrassed that's
why you don't have yeah I see dogs with
bigger nuts oh my gosh wait wait your
nuts went down yeah
your testes go oh we can shut down and
they just shrivel up no what you should
tell the girls though is oh
what I what happens to your testicles is
it's it's it's a fighting thing it's
when when my body feels like it's in
danger my testicles go inside my body
it's a fight thing yes so it's
protecting me it's protecting me so when
I have an erection it's protecting my
nuts my nuts go down yeah I got giant
nuts what happened you're not sir
shrunk they shrunk so much by the way
bro it feels like it's almost like it's
it's gripping your nut sack oh that
sounds awesome it's kind of crazy it has
two mosquito bites for nuts what the
[ __ ] what did the doctor say about that
you do too really she has two pimples
for nuts now Brian has the biggest Brian
has I got no hold nothing hold on Brian
has big red nuts like a Great Dane
Brian's nuts are you saying are
shaffir's nuts it's like one nut that
has a moon nut that goes around it oh
wow it's like this giant with a tiny
satellite nut see Brian's bronzer like
two grandfather clocks just that's gross
that is gross
now when you whip it out for the for
like you're married now but when you
were single and you whip it out was
there that moment like I hope these
don't scare this woman off it's like
Frankenstein we have to peel it out it
takes a minute you peel it like a fruit
there we go it's still coming whoa
there's there he is oh [ __ ] it's a big
bag of nuts boy he's running backwards
he rocked he got rocked yeah oh here we
go oh oh oh he's going down one more of
those one more of those he's eight I
feel like uh positive is a little old
nothing worse than one punch in the face
when you're moving backwards mm-hmm
great cardio Murano all right that's
what I'm saying
was he training for another fight and
they just moved him up not Murano he
just showed up he showed up he was at
Home Depot working
there you go man yes
George he's got a good chin man yeah for
now for now almost
Curious George is crushing it right now
are they still doing Curious George
books I don't know my son watches the
cartoon that was my first book mine was
where's Waldo and I'm like Hey Dad
that's why I suck at reading no my first
by the way this fight's about to get in
this fight's getting interesting because
Moreno's a little tired right now and
he's taking some ah Ponce nebio's on
death's doorsteps
he's exhausted he got beat up
there's a clip coming in I wonder if
it's hard
oh my God oh my gosh done oh my God he
just was like stunts
he needed that one oh my God
his face looks like he had a seizure huh
there you go he's got he kept getting he
gets hands hands are down his face kind
of was like turn off punches right
turned off your whole election you see
his face he just went uh oh that was
rough
last round
that was crazy
is that sort of title shot now boy look
at this
big feet damn look at those feet
the big ones that were size 17.
who's that guy
oh you got the [ __ ] get out of here yeah
yes watch this watch this boom watch his
face again don't move backwards let's
see his face oh yeah oh oh yeah that's
his body that Bell's Palsy immediately
he went straight Justin Bieber
watch watch boom oh he broke his jaw
that's what is that what was that what
happened well it's weird
but it's also weird for his face to make
it look see how it's staying there it
might be broken if it looks like a mini
strokes yeah it looks like little I hope
he's all right I hope he's [ __ ] okay
really
hard that's Anderson Silva's all
striking go she's a great guy he's had
an American top team
that's excited you would be excited he
was losing that fight too he was losing
that fight
Bieber Bieber's face just quit on him
he's better now yeah I think he came
back yeah Bell's Palsy is how about his
his uh that's exhausting gorgeous wife
had some serious medical problems what's
she have
I think there was a blood clot yeah man
I don't think this helps with blood
clots but you need to get on some Kratom
from Happy Hippo it's the Limitless pill
for people out there best focused
product I've ever used thanks man best
product it's all natural that's right
it's all natural
all-natural kratom's like the CBD would
used to be is like the wild west you
know who to trust you can trust my
friends at happy hippo they got it all I
use the concentrated uh Kratom shot it's
the cherry flavor little pink thing that
a cute little Pink Hippo on there visit
happyhippo.com use promo code thick boy
for 20 software life use that code as
many times you want sent to your brother
your nephews your aunt your uncle your
gay uncles it doesn't matter go to
happyhippo.com use promo codes thick boy
20 off for life
boom boom boom
yeah that's the fat game the fat game uh
see I don't think his Jaws broke uh
Frank because like he's normal there no
I think he just had yes he just said I
had that fight one I agree with him and
then he just kind of got hit there well
you know but Sam what happened to
um Bieber's wife she got problems too
yeah
oh that's right
so you hear about that guy in uh the the
Olympics you know what the uh World Cup
he was like tweeting and doing videos
he's like I got really everyone here's
got really bad cough
no but he said his brother suspects Foul
Play yeah but he would he was talking he
was because he wore like a a gay pride
shirt right yeah I mean which is frowned
upon out there rare in Qatar they said
you can't do that
and then he was found dead
but he was he supposedly was talking
about how he was not feeling good yeah
okay so some people do get heart attacks
it could be a coincidence but also Sam
you fans herself conspiracy theory so
what do you think happened here
what do you think Sam
I mean dude I I don't know about you
guys man but listen I do this show at
the comic stores called comedy chaos we
you know the best we used to put the
names and everybody on the on the
Marquee we haven't been able to do that
because every time I do a show there's a
a rest in peace
I mean every time Comics keep passing
away Comics Keep just one right after
another it's a conspiracy well I don't I
don't know what I've never seen this
before
some are some are punches people are
dying yeah you think maybe just friends
are getting older Sam yeah like changing
the guard I don't know I mean some of
it's fentanyl oh fentanyl get you [ __ ]
yeah it is fennel real don't do cocaine
yeah I don't know how you still do this
day and age yeah now they're talking
about giving out those tests but also if
you're doing cocaine you're not like
hold on before we snort this somebody
test it it's like give me that you're a
risk taker you're not gonna test it you
should I've never done cocaine me
neither I've never smoked a cigarette
I'll do something nothing nothing Brian
gets the nose for it oh yeah oh yeah
Sam you you fancy yourself some coke
Sam had his uh two-year sobriety uh
yesterday congratulations thank you yeah
two years of being a quitter yeah
that's a proper response there you go
that's a big deal
um do you feel better Sam life is better
every morning Sam what do you think of
these these three crypto billionaires
that started those funds who both all
died one of the guys said he was afraid
I think it's four now it's yeah and then
one guy died and was in a pool with his
keys Walling everything and then so the
night before he's tweeting Bitcoin the
whole thing the crypto the whole all the
all this stuff has just crashed it's all
crashed it's not coming back no but it's
like gangsters had a lot of money in
that [ __ ] like right the Russians they
screwed over a lot of people
well these exchanges everybody is like
everybody is like oh we need to regulate
everything that they did is illegal
already you don't need to regulate it
they broke laws that are already on the
books how so well I mean like what they
did was they took
they took he took money from his
investors that like so let's say you go
on FTX and you buy Bitcoin right
they didn't give you a Bitcoin they gave
you a IOU they took your money and then
they moved it to this thing called
Alameda yeah listen once you're doing
you're involved in something that's not
regulated you need some bad people
involved yeah but then you're messing
with the wrong people and you got some
rushing gangsters that you you know took
their money they don't
is a giant money laundering scheme and
he became the number one or number two
donor to the Democrats he was also I
don't trust those billionaires are like
oh I'm so rich I drive a Prius and I
wear sandals it's like you're hiding
something I don't trust any billionaire
that wears a backpack sorry Nikolai he's
got 29 years old 30 and now 53 we're all
outstanding crypto luminaries who passed
away within a matter of weeks of each
other yeah yeah this one that's a little
this is what's easy to figure out this
is Ronda Rousey looking great no she's
doing the WWE thing she has to stay in
shape
how is she on WWE that's great I don't
watch WWE but from my what I hear she's
really good at it
she said she'd come out of retirement if
she could fight Gina Carano
all right well
that's pretty cool she always has a
serious face intense human being very
intense speaking of intense
uh Dan is looking older just like me his
body's got a lot better because the
memory saw that guy and told him if he
keeps look he's gonna live to live yeah
he lost a bunch of 10 more years yeah he
got pretty shredded all Natty
yeah that uh holiday that guy and his uh
prediction
it's not a science no that's called
documents it's called a gimmick yes
you know like seeing a psychic yeah
what psychics are real
some of them Long Island Medium I
believe her
do you believe in ghosts hell yeah and I
love it paranormal all day how about how
about like Bigfoot and Dogma me too all
day dog no no I'm saying I don't you
don't believe in that I think back in
the day but not now what do you mean
they just quit I think maybe they they
went extinct I I believe back in the day
there was some Bigfoot [ __ ] but not now
you believe in Giants dude Nephilim bro
we'd see them do
by now we'd see them you'd find like
Bigfoot [ __ ] somewhere wouldn't you like
or it's some sort of oh they're into
they could be inter-dimensional
they could be on a different vibration
this is where you lose me Sam why I was
on board we were on the same wave here I
I've been with my girl for 20 years you
sound like you watch too much Rick and
Morty we're not married twins married
in California you're married
I don't think there is half of whatever
the hell she might be listening please
stop no luckily I gave her money she's
at the casino if not more oh please stop
yes and if you have a house it's yours
yeah in California look at you come come
along dude if you're married for 10
years you have to give them
five thousand dollars a month for the
rest of their life wait wait wait wait
stop
filming five thousand oh really yeah
Frank's ex-wife used to be the the mayor
of uh Montana really on the show
Yellowstone hold on
the mayor of Montana like the entire
State played the character on the show
Yellowstone but it's Governor right
governor oh that's right governor who am
I to judge you now it's John Dutton I'll
tell you what though on Yellowstone
they're not very hairy you know what
they're using manscape and it's brought
to you this episode of cowboys fight
companions brought to you by manscape
called Segway B there it is Buddy
manscape the global leaders and below
the ways grooming are leaving 2022 with
brand new products they got The Preserve
cologne the preserved body wash 2023 I
can't believe it's 20 23 we're all done
soon is the year to up your hygiene
fellas and smell fantastic at manscaped
they want to help you do that with a
special offer go to manscape.com CFC and
you get 20 off and free shipping take
the leap into the new year and join the
7 million Bros who are already trusting
manscaped they got you and they're
giving you the performance package 4.0
it's everything you need they got the
lawnmower 4.0 they got the weed whacker
the nose ear trimmer if you have air
here you're just disgusting all right oh
it's disgusting I mean take care of it
nose hair your nose hair connects your
mustache oh you're single the wall let
manscape help you out all right and get
their new preserved cologne you're gonna
smell like a reindeer all right like a
clean reindeer
dessert they sound clean or that's a bad
yeah reindeer after after
a heavy effort it runs through a heavy
rainfall yes
my kid my son your son's hairy manscape
I mean in the bathroom before you do it
before you do it Frank you can get your
son 20 off by going to manscape.com
free shipping I was hoping you'd have it
here in the studio I do have some for
you here yeah get 25 for your son you're
for your hairy son get 20 off and free
shipping he's 13 here all over I mean I
walked in the bathroom I was like holy
get twins and free shipping by go to
manscape.com CFC Happy New Year to your
nuts what were you saying your son's
hair yeah he's 17 18 18. it's about that
time I mean he's Bush eyebrows beautiful
eyebrows and yeah oh yeah handsome kids
but but your son has those Ernie and
bird eyebrows huh yes yes Portuguese his
mother's his mother's Portuguese I
didn't know that and beautiful Montana
stunningly beautiful oh dude
yeah
she's she's in John Dutton got it oh
yeah does that bother you no no it's
good for her man brutal she just didn't
I just uh I was doing a movie in Puerto
Rico and the actress dropped out and I
called up Wendy I said you come down
she's so good man I got her paid oh
that's great yeah yeah it's oh she's a
great mom too she's so good I know he's
done it for 25 years these two she uh
she when she was
30 I would look at her in the morning I
wake up and go
oh my God you're the prettiest girl I've
ever seen in my life I remember you said
that you felt lucky huh oh yeah I mean
she was stunning we'd be eating dinner
and he'd go look at it I'm so attracted
to my wife I'm still [ __ ] I still
look beautiful yeah yeah she's gorgeous
I am now this guy comes out of bilal's
camp but that might mean he comes out of
AKA and and khabib's Camp I'm not sure
no you just so you gave two different
camps there right B so Jared Gordon he's
a brown belt under uh he's a brown bear
he's a brown belt under John danhurst
okay that's that's scary so Patty pimlet
you know he's a Grappler he's very
gifted as a Grappler and there's blue
Muhammad our boy Muhammad but um there
he is there he is so wow Patty pimlin
you know he usually gets it done uh on
the ground but it's gonna be dicey
because if you're a brown belt under
John danhart your black belt mainly
everywhere else yeah so it's interesting
to see how Patty gets this done I do
think this is Patty's coming out party I
think he will be ranked in the top 15
after this fight what is he now he's not
even right isn't that amazing they're
pushing him who's that guy with the
ponytails the piggy tails oh no he has
two pigtails which is very so aggressive
Jimmy Smith on that's an aggressive look
the lock in the cage I love Jimmy he was
talking about how like Patty's super
interesting because like the UFC's
pushing him but it's like one of these
it's like the first time that like this
Rising Star isn't like annihilating
everybody like like you remember
Anderson Silva would just like go
through everybody they go through
everybody now Patty's interesting
because I don't have a food truck and
his manager goes because Patty was uh
the cage Warrior Champion which Biz
being Conor McGregor uh Hardy came out
of there like Savages coming out of
there and he was a champion of that and
he was like dude over we're we're in
England in the UK he's a bigger star
than Conor he's huge they call him the
fifth Beetle yeah he can't walk down the
street no he's huge he's a huge
celebrity I just did his podcast he's a
really great such a good dude great
great dude yeah you pass you the batty
he's and he he just has it man he just
does he's gonna he has that arrogance
where people it might turn some people
off when you're around him like oh he's
just a joy to be around like yeah and
he's smart he's so funny
that's like the most technical street
fight you've ever seen no like him and
this other guy are fighting in there in
the in the hallway school and this guy
knows this [ __ ] too yeah it's like a
super technical [ __ ] Cat Williams in
that middle schooler in the yard oh yeah
that's so funny that was a good fight
is that a weird weird moments there
super funny though took a proper [ __ ]
probably [ __ ] I can't stand it a proper
[ __ ] sloppy [ __ ] and I hate that
but dude the British love their Fighters
bro
the fighters and uh soccer players
my favorite thing was on the last
pay-per-view
one of the guys they were showing was
wearing my podcast shirt oh really yeah
it was great
Patty the bay he's a superstar man and
he you know he blows up in between
fights he said he was going to stop
doing that yeah he'll get to like 215.
look at him he's a baby he's so young
man that's my thing though like this is
I I don't agree with this fight form at
this level like I think you keep
building him up he's such a star let me
get experience because this is a really
tough fight for him he's fighting this
this straight up wizard on the ground I
mean that he's a wizard though too yeah
that's his strength yeah his gift is
grapple I thought it was more oh really
no no no he's he's his strength is on
the ground this would be interesting to
see him we go against a john danaher
brown belt though we'll see what happens
but Patty's a yeah freak on the ground
you gotta watch your ankles gotta watch
the Yankees right or not as much as an
MMA no of course an MMA especially if
you're drawn down still got that thing
there it's on the other side what is it
is it what is it it's like is it cancer
it's always cancer it's that oh that's
from my that's from my rogue
it's amazing how this he's like a
wrestler from 1980s you know we
like you know wrestle at 134 and play
football is 180 pounds
my heart he gets so massive yeah season
stopped doing it when I'm on my food
truck he was literally like 215 right
now look at him and I told what's he
fighting yet 155 oh [ __ ] and this he
came on food truck ate more food than I
did of course and then I go Patty you
know you doing the stun professional man
like you're so big I left the UFC
offered you like a short nose fight like
a title shot he started laughing why
would I take a short notice fight I make
too much money that's the advantage you
guys have now you know makes so much
money outside the outcome I would never
rush into a big fight it doesn't make
sense how did he pull how did he become
this just his hair his personality he
has it all he checks everything about
this dude forever forever and again it
comes from cage Warriors and now listen
he was a cage Warrior Champion he'd sell
out the arena where the UFC fight before
the UFC came there so when this UFC came
there he sold it off he sold it out and
he was like first on the main card he's
he sold it not the veterans in the UFC
he sold it USANA so when the they came
to the UFC the first time he turned it
down because I'll take a pay cut I go to
the UFC and I'm fighting better doesn't
make sense so he turned it down kept
fighting in the cage Warriors and then
after two years his manager was like we
gotta get to the UFC man if you want to
like reach your optimal kind of talent
we got to get into the UFC so it's like
all right let's do it and he took a
picture dude look at this [ __ ] look at
all this bag oh you have no idea man
massive look at them people love him and
here's the other thing I'm glad he talks
about uh suicide too because he lost one
of his best friends a suicide yes oh you
did the podcast with him because yeah he
called me he heard me on Jay Glazier and
he was oh I love Jay yeah I know Jay
well and uh and we talked a lot about
men's mental health really yeah he's a
big I didn't know you did his podcast
yeah he's a big just recently like two
weeks ago oh wow he had Dana White on
too was great why because he lost it he
lost his he lost a close friend to it
yeah don't return fight week yeah so
he's dealing with that gets on the mic
he was like Hey felony it's in London
he's like fellas if you're hurting talk
to somebody talk to somebody talk to him
yeah talk to somebody he's really a stud
man
I just don't this fight again I think he
checks all the boxes he has the closest
thing when you get to Connor in a long
time if he's the next Conor yeah I just
you got to build him give him time let
me because he he's not there yet he's
not a top 15 guy skill wise yet I mean
he's only 27 years old Long Reach I like
that let me ask you something dude so
when you watch when you watch Connor's
rise favorite moment of all time in
sports right
Connor is an amazing fighter obviously
right
if you look at like where he made his
legacy off it was against smaller
Fighters watch him when he gets to his
run it's it's again I'm talking about
Eddie Alvarez Eddie Alvarez Mendes Jose
Aldo yeah so then he goes to 155 and
he's fighting dudes but that's why there
are weight classes you're right
so I'm he's great but everyone wants him
at 155 he's had a he but that 45 pound
cut is hard yeah
juicy I'm just saying there's a juice
and Dana White on Patty's podcast goes
the next fight for Connor is probably
gonna be when he comes back to me
Michael Chan and Chandler's a slight
Underdog in that fight yeah well because
he's going to try to box he tries to
bang with Connor he's well that's what
Chandler does so when Connor came back I
know you want to give him a fight it
should have been Tony Ferguson versus
khabib versus uh Showtime Pettis versus
correct Conor McGregor yes that should
have been the fight but they bring him
back and it just but that but that I see
to me with Connor especially with this
laugh I like the Chandler fight there's
some heat there yes but you know it's
Conor McGregor so you can he can jump
the queue and get the title shot but if
I'm in college team like we need a win
bro we need to win so let's fight Tony
first and get get your whistle wet that
ain't an easy fight but it's an easier
fight than mochachev
he's gonna fight Chandler which again
it's no Cakewalk and one channel is
gonna be 170 as well
I think they haven't agreed I haven't
heard about the weight yet I would
assume it's at uh 70 because Connor's
super juicy right now super Juice I do
not want to see Patty lose oh I'm
rooting more for him than anybody on
this card me too I wish that a chick
would take her mask off in the back
well covet is rising now 170 Patty is it
170. yeah that makes sense oh boy 55
wouldn't make sense for Connor oh boy
he's so much bigger than him dude he is
he's so much bigger than him this other
guy no he's not he's a lot smaller he
kind of looks like that other guy the
mini the little brown dummy just with
Terry with Brian's hair yeah
I'm telling you man they're putting
these
take out these white guys yeah what's
going on here little Browns are
terrorizing this guy's Patty loses it's
a sad day for England
oh but to Patty's defense he always says
I like to get hit in the first round
which I told him I don't like that no
because you get to a certain level where
you can't eat those shots you still can
against Gordon but when you get to the I
mean I know I I dude I'm the first thing
from any kind of real fighter but man a
lot of these guys keep their hands down
bro he just got caught there throw kicks
you know Connor started a lot of that
all the time now
time man I don't like that
Patty keeps his chin away but if you're
a Patty fan you know he always gets hit
especially early on and he says he needs
it to get into the fight which it drives
me nuts but that's his thing so don't be
too alarmed if you're a Paddy fan strong
kid Patty Patty's athletic though he's
not shooting [ __ ] kid man
well he gets ripped doesn't he yeah he
does he gets ready I can't emphasize
listen it's hard to make me look
he was so thick on the food truck thick
as [ __ ] right not like healthy either he
looked like Brendan uh Frazier from the
whale movie click on that click on that
Padres picture
he looks like dirt novinsky there yeah
but I got seven foot tall and skinny he
looks like Brendan Fraser from the whale
bring up Brendan Fraser the whale chin
so people get the reference oh boy
and then say it again so they could die
sir Gordon he's no joke Gordon's [ __ ]
Gordon's sitting in that cup man
oh my God there's there's Patty pamlett
wow in the off season
uh they say Brendan Fraser is going to
win the Oscar how they how'd they get
himself I love that like you can win an
Oscar for playing ugly how'd they get
him so heavy you're so brave for Charlie
right Charlene uh what's her name
Charlene there's on did he actually
transform to that is that what he looks
like for real I don't know oh so he's
gonna get an Oscar and have to wear a
fat suit
dude you're telling me there's no fat
Hollywood actors talk about
biased yeah for sure Patty keeps you
tell me he couldn't find a fat actor to
play that we're hiring skinny guys yeah
Hollywood's lost their minds Hollywood
has lost their mind yikes man
this fight is uh this guy's nose isn't
looking bad's making me nervous whose
noses
it's only making Heroes because you want
him to win yeah if you're a Paddy face
remember to be it's his first like real
big test it's his big test but yeah I
know that but but this what stressed me
out then he'll be ranked the top 15
practice then what I know that's the
problem it stresses me out because you
want to take care of passes his hands
seem to be very down oh
that's that's going to happen so often
if he fights God look how big patty is
too many of these guys the fifth Beetle
folks
the fifth field he's a very rugged guy
though he's a [ __ ] rugged kid man oh
man oh he's getting shot put the head
though right look at that boom Oh I hope
that he has all that hair that just goes
it makes it look great yeah when you
have a mop and it flaps like that it
look makes it look worse even if you
don't block the show his hands are down
down yeah it's like I'm gonna keep my
hands right down here and just throw
see that
backs up too it's not we don't want to
stay in the pocket no no but I mean you
need to hit oh he needs to hit the
uppercut I wish he would shoot but you'd
probably oh oh see I don't like that I
don't either I don't either I don't
either he's just
the lights right or body strikes this
guy's not taking the kind of damage that
Patty is man
his face is red his nose looks broke oh
man Patty's catching those hooks
oh
oh
this just now this week it's interesting
see I'd rather see him down here than on
the feet me too but I don't want Patty
on his back but I'd rather see this
chess match he's trying to set up a
triangle right now
yep or go go Plata there you go go Plata
Central that's Eddie Bravo Mission
Control am I right Sam Mission Control
knives so everybody knows King not
everywhere like recently or young keen
Ivory like like about 10 years ago [ __ ]
yeah dude I'd brag about that all day
he's calm he's fine
and then she said I'll see
water oh yeah you're sober
uh we probably give that round to Patty
with a takedown at the end I don't know
I don't know now he got caught in the
head a lot on the show I did I did say
decision I said this goes the decision
because the tough how he got taken down
no Patty took him down yeah he did but
then he got reversed so you're the best
and they ended the fight on his back ah
you might give it to Gordon our boy
Gordon hit him in the face as much as he
hit him in the face look at that look at
those shots yeah and if you're watching
the judge that hair flipping makes it
seem like it's a harder punch right am I
gonna need you to stop saying Hereford
okay he has said it's here here here
waddling what are we gonna call that see
that though you see who's getting the
better of these exchanges it's not Patty
and Patty did end the round on his back
yeah probably give that round to Gordon
100 percent
give me some of that Patty's Patty's a
slow starter I can't believe that guy's
so British in the background yeah holy
[ __ ] what are you an extra in a guy
Richie film taxi driver I love guy reach
even though
oh yeah this has a little bit in it
though
oh come on now when you aren't making
that dude did they give you different
tastes okay two years two years to get
it rolling just different flavors all
sorts it took forever and then just to
get the blessing from the Japanese it's
a beast why Wow
because Japanese won't give just any
Americans a 10-year aged whiskey I have
to find a certain connection
you have to meet with the Yakuza bro
they got dicey oh really let me tell you
the time I went to get a massage
and that like a dude came out and you
like Yakuza [ __ ] tattoos really
you're being rubbed down I'm like
oh man I thought these are gonna be
chicks
oh I can't do Mel
I've had some Russian men work me good
of course
you're such a submission putting a judo
uh gold medalist in college in in the
Olympics no dude are we sober no I don't
remember
yeah the male it would be a better job
but I just can't I can't relax no
me either man
you guys you guys think about jerking
you off it's the worst
this kid this kid is [ __ ]
he's coming Patty some problems Patty
would take him down here we don't want
Patty no notice Pat this is going
backwards shots one shots him but he's
on his back foot yeah
is he doing any damage with these punch
because this guy keeps moving forward
this guy's keeping
hey you know what I don't like I don't
like how Brian's going for the other guy
oh look at this oh oh okay
what is that that's a sneaky little move
is that a choke bro
um yeah because he has it yeah it is
weird
be tough to finish man yeah
he tried Patty's got enough confidence
to try weird [ __ ] Mike did you did you
say the nuts said they think Patty
towards ACO no no Darren tale oh gotcha
all right
UFC's like dude I feel like Darren I
don't want what we're gonna say right it
just feels like he's just it's he's not
fully in okay one foot in one foot and I
just think he's on hard times he gets to
find himself whenever a guy changes
camps those alarms
for a minute I thought he was done he
came back for a while and just different
different animal Charles Oliveira was on
a rough streak so you're with comes out
comes out can teach you some wrestling
mom's odd ditch the kids it looked like
he wasn't I don't know
there wasn't a lot of wrestling but just
because you train with a guy doesn't
mean too much people put so much
emphasis on it it's like you're not
harmful take the [ __ ] oh [ __ ] idiot I
mean you need to get back to the center
of the octagon and go forward Patty
pamlett yeah how did he go out on the
shield too now come on Patty come on
that uppercut is so there but he keeps
throwing it down no he's missing oh [ __ ]
but this kid's firing back
Gordon's disciplined
see how he keeps laying here
you sound like my dad when he watches a
football game every single play Blitz
Blitz bro I love a good Blitz I like to
Blitz myself it Blitz every time dad
smells oh my God I'm a Raiders fan you
guys suck this year oh my God I'm a
Broncos fan how about this dude how
about we lose to people who've just came
off the street
like we lose the people that weren't
with the team the week before yeah Jeff
Saturday or the Colts yeah
you had a little surprise for you guys
you know Baker Mayfield is supposed to
be here tonight oh really the Rams made
him do a Christmas party but I had I was
gonna surprise you guys oh we love that
I know I know you would Brian
I know Baker Mayfield look what he's
doing with Heisman Trophy winner but
Oklahoma oh there you go B come on baby
I've done my work
Baker Mayfield's no joke come on upper I
like I like guys like that yep yep a
long uppercut though dude Gordon's
giving it up this is a hell of a fight
but Gordon let's get him out get it get
him into this cockfight and shoot like
Gordon has to knock him out or choke him
out right to win there's no way that
anybody's gonna give him yeah poked this
is this is I don't know this is Frasier
Ali here kids oh that's so aggressive
hey hit the [ __ ] [ __ ]
the shower
go get go get one of those keto [ __ ]
brownies and hit the [ __ ] hey what I say
guys
right wow guys
Ryan's like this is better than Force
Griffin Stefan Bonner top Ultimate
Fighter finale guys sorry I gotta look I
gotta look excited sometimes guys
apologies
probably not an appropriate
oh Daddy's starting to Pieces him up
well use that reach Patrick
Patty's a nightmare you think his real
name is Patrick Patrick look at him
Patty the bad Patrick the Baddie look at
him he's into it oh boy here we go guys
I gotta get a [ __ ] brownie I think do
you want those keto Browns
not in front of me or not no Frank sir
you have young children and you're 75
years old that's so true
so I think the fight's 1-1 yeah yeah
hey Gordon won the first round Patty won
the second yeah
Brian's putting his Invisalign again and
then he's gonna take him out Ryan grab
me a white claw
let's get come down to this third round
yeah it's definitely
I don't know this guy looks good Gordon
looks like he's he's uh
you follow football Sam yeah you see my
uh University of Colorado got Deion
Sanders yeah I think he's yeah you know
it's like crazy that people are pissed
they would leave Jackson say I go of
course he's gonna leave he's gonna leave
Colorado if it works out 100 because you
can get to Florida State eventually
that's the Michigan or Ohio State like
it will be before God damn Santa's gone
to college football to stay at Jackson
no that's only other famous black people
who are mad yeah they're like we thought
we're gonna stay there and make it a
Powerhouse he's like [ __ ] that's not
the goal yeah the goal is to get to the
top no he gave a great speech about
about it and he was so eloquent in what
he said he's great in the Dion way yeah
I don't like the filming of telling kids
to get to in the portal oh I love that
really the losers they're one and eleven
yeah those are kids I know but you're
they're losers right and that's a moment
you like kind of go hey man I'm here you
guys are 111. guys hit the portal oh he
just smashed his face and
has it 2018 since we've got a hater on
our hands and I like 2018 for who for
Gordon disagree with that no I think
it's one I think it's one last round
unless he had a 10-8 no wait that's not
10-8 round it's hard to get 10 8.
would you get me a cookie you got one
the Orioles
Vegas last night no he went to Adam
Sandler's show oh who and I think Rob
Schneider opened for Adam Saleh
the person great person oh he's the best
really good basketball player
shot Hoops oh yeah bro that get dude
these movies that he's putting out that
have basketball themes are the best
movies bro puts all his buddies in
they're playing anyway so he's like
let's make this a movie dude that one
about the guy that he finds in Spain or
whatever that was such a good movie he's
crying uncut gems is great bro yeah one
of the best movies ever I don't see it
oh you didn't see it's so stressful
really oh it's so good at your age with
that heart I don't know buddy yeah we
got a good archive that movie will
stretch you out
that's where home girl who's Kanye
West's girlfriend uh blew up really oh
she was impossible on that movie
that the the girl Connie's girl
ex-girlfriend the only problem I had
with Sandlers is when he had what's his
Queen Latifah as his wife
in which movie in the in the new one the
basketball one yeah you know what he's
doing there I know what he's doing there
but Beyonce wasn't available
nobody else the the blue girl dude my
favorite thing is Queen Latifah is like
an action hero and The Equalizer like
what are we doing here yeah guys this is
stop talking we gotta watch this fight
there's only two and a half minutes left
come on hold on just just look at uh
Julia Fox over there I know Julia oh
yeah you do you know who's hot oh that
Carissa for Amazon Prime games I haven't
seen it the blonde oh
this is a great fight great fight this
is Amazon Prime games Ali Frazier this
is oh yeah Chris by the way Patty oh
[ __ ] they got a break they gotta break
away though she was a uh uh NFL Fox
reporter yeah
Amazon pictures oh come on come on here
we go oh she's still doing football here
we go I thought you were talking about
like she's so hot bro
really oh here we go yeah dude this is
pretty cool Frank is that was she's cute
she's hot
damn Frank no that's no she's cute
very pretty
I think she's hot you know uh the Ted
Bundy series
oh I didn't want I don't watch any of
that serial killer [ __ ] what I can't
drive me nuts why because one I was
alive when it happened I knew what was
all going on I don't need to like it's
like you don't want to recap you're
frustrating bro it's being a stand-up
comic and having people come to the
comedy club and get offended by jokes
and then run home and watch Dahmer you
know but you know what's going on here
is is there is there um you know Dominic
it's the most watched show ever on
Netflix beat out the square games over 1
billion views no I didn't so Netflix
went oh this is what people want so now
they're doing the John Wayne Gacy yeah
they're doing well I mean glorify let's
glorify Netflix is low frequency what do
you mean it's they it's meant to put on
oh it might be over that's not a good
chance
he's too high he's gonna fall off yeah
he's getting on top yeah
oh watch those legs Daddy oh oh Patty
specialist on the back he's a back
specialist 30 seconds Patty ooh Patty's
losing this fight huh I think he's gonna
win it I don't I don't think so Sam I
definitely lost this round unless he
does something we'll allow this guy I
think they'll give it to Patty you think
there's some foul play here I think I
think it's gonna when you're when you're
up sound like Patty
it's every bite the the New York the
Nevada athletic commission UFC everybody
wants this guy to win he sells more
tickets everyone makes
let's see what happens ah yeah I don't
know
draw I never really picked fights until
I watch it when I'm dead sorry would be
actually it'd be a drawing by the way
he's fine he doesn't have a mark on him
he doesn't have a mark on him not a
[ __ ] Mark on him
caught a lot of hot shots so I don't
know
let me see Boop great left hook that was
there all night beautiful laptop
dude who am I to talk boom boop boop I
got bad angles but man you gotta keep
those hands up yes he does
Patty won that another Exchange
the second one they showed yeah boom
I wish Patty with a shot more after
throwing gloves
that could have been bad for the knee
there but he's okay because he got out
of this though and then reversed it but
it still counts as a takedown for that
gentleman there
you got Patty case I think Patty wins
this maybe he didn't actually I was
talking about I was talking about
Jeffrey Dahmer uh
a big uh keto George who do you have
who do you have George's who do you have
patty patty across the unanimous patio
over here no I think it's a draw like
Frank but you were listening you're
listening let's talk about Dahmer he's
talking about true but I didn't watch
Fox
Y and points
horny Patty I don't have I don't have
Point Patty on points you have a losing
B two to one I'm afraid I'm afraid so
possibly yeah
it's me a dark Day in England
I'm afraid I have him losing yeah they
lost the uh they lost world cup I was
wearing my England Jersey and two I felt
stupid
decision Patty feedback Split Decision
Patty I give him the last time I hope
you guys are right
because he didn't give one hell of a
speech too the other guy's not even very
good speech
Patty's spotted up
oh unanimous gonna go to Patty then
yeah I totally wow there's no way you a
dude like that you got a beat you gotta
either knock him out or choke them up my
man Patty you can't have a close one I
want that he's gonna be a great speech
too
how about you just uh word it what he's
saying just
I knew it
look at him he looks like he's fishing
Joe said that was a close one Patty's
like no it's not
oh definitely close also if I'm the UFC
hey slow down with this kid let him get
his bearings underneath he has all the
Superstar qualities do that they did
with sugar until they tossed him with
Peter yawn but now they're even pull him
back with Peter Young I'm sorry with
Suga because you know he's not getting
the title shot now
I don't know why people like Mr Bean
it's not my thing I hate slapstick
a third
well I thought he lost the first I
thought he lost him first the takedown I
thought he lost the first he seems
totally fine he was taking yes she could
see two and three I thought the third
with the takedown at the end gave to the
other guy but
look at him with his arm around you
what a great guy what a character
assume suicide go on a limb here though
he's a good kid does this move him up it
moves him up because he just beat that
guy who's on to you know it's a big win
for him but I think it needs the UFC
needs to go okay we're not tossing the
top 10 guy we're gonna talk toss him a
top 15 guy I think
I hope and hopefully the people that
no no no no
and uh he's worried about a
um Bubba how long are you in L.A where
you go off to another movie soon uh no I
go to
um Frank
I go to uh a film festival in Europe for
this movie that I have coming out what
movie it's uh it's like it's like death
wish it's called um
uh uh Little Dixie hey you know you're
doing too many movies when you you gotta
you're like I'm I'm doing this no it's
it's uh who's in it uh myself and uh
Eric Dane you know yeah uh and um Peter
Green some cool people and uh but it's
me playing Charles Bronson oh cool oh
yeah dude like that sounds bad that's
badass hell yeah it does
um sounds amazing so I don't leave till
January I'm in town moving into my new
house
she had some time to chill yeah now
when's the Bronco come and this week oh
it's from this week which is funny
because I bought the Bronco before the
house the Broncos a lot of money yeah
and so is the house and then I needed a
car so I went and got that BMW so my
business manager is like hey uh Brad
Pitt yeah you might want to slow the
roll yeah chill out a little bit
are we talking to Bronco a car I got a
uh from Max leader out in Chicago they
built me from the ground up a 67 Bronco
what's the company name Max leader Max
Lube yeah Jesus bring that [ __ ] up those
retro Broncos are so hard yeah
my buddy sad when he just sold it I
could have hooked you up he had a blue
one restored they're great oh blue
that's my blue bench seating
this guy's a killer oh my God is a
Savage Jesus Christ who you got
Mega Med I got mine now but it but I
think people will be surprised John's
not that easy to take down it's Max
leader Motors
m-a-x-l-i-d-e-r and it's in Chicago chin
oh he's a [ __ ] killer yeah so anyway
it's got It's got this great coyote uh
that's those are the new ones that's
that you just go back
um don't even know these days
this one
it's the Vintage one the one on the left
yeah when you clicked on it had it at
the top so vintage yeah
it's cool they hook up the newer ones
too they do everything this guy's just
so that's pretty cool that's a nice car
yeah there it is that's what it looked
like it's weird it flashes away I know
it's really strange what color is yours
Frank Black yeah so see the see the one
in the left corner yeah so that's what
it looks like but black yeah but black
tan and tear or black into it's uh it's
it's a uh it's kind of a wine color
interior it's really badass so what's
your blacked out filthy and it's got a
coyote fight there it's got that engine
the coyote and that's the same one that
comes in the Raptor Bronco yeah it's a
beast of an engine Savages do you guys
like power slap no it makes no sense to
me
to me that's something you go on
skateboards and falling and like in my
[ __ ] puckers exactly it's not I'm not
well there's no like there's no brain
damage it's just weird power slap is not
interesting to know women are doing it
I'm like what what's happening are guys
slapping women no
because I'm definitely not watching I'm
just
put my pants on dude I wanna I'm honest
I'm not into that arm wrestling is
becoming our old Italian fathers some of
the athletes
yeah it's a weird thing but it's a trend
in the UFC you know they Dana and the
fertittas invested in the business so
they did yeah that's what that's an ad
for the new league the slap fighting
League anybody in here could do it no I
you know I do love bare knuckle
he was like this dude just wasn't like
it's not pretty fine like I just made it
ugly he wasn't ready he thought he was
gonna sit back and do his things like
you know I just didn't give him a niche
damn he said I made it ugly man I can't
believe Perry oh he's so so fun
he's like Florida bro that's Florida
yeah well Thiago Alba's is uh the 55
pound champion I think or there he is T
Albus yeah Houston Alexander they get a
lot of guys
Houston Alexander's still fighting and
bare knuckle he is
Alan belcher's the heavyweight champion
why are some of the pictures black and
white are they still with us
that's a good point I don't know why
they're doing that look at Oh there's uh
Bostwick uh he's a stud
[ __ ] well why are I don't know man
bear knuckle fighting to me is like the
it's too much hardcore gangbang of
fighting you know just like when you
watch those pornos you're like that's
too much yeah
I mean not for nothing two guys are
wearing four ounce gloves it's not that
much different yeah correct you know
those gloves do nothing you got guys
like like uh Tyson Fury wearing 10
ounces that's nothing like George
Foreman with a townhouse Club Heyday
dude it's almost better getting hit with
a with a fist
and they get blood email it's just the
knuckles and the bare hands it just cuts
these guys out look at him man [ __ ]
strong every time you see
Middle Eastern Amish you know troubles
coming dude you know what's weird about
all these pakistanians watch this this
is the thing watch his hair it doesn't
change the entire fight his striking he
could be in a bulldog choke and his hair
will not move correct it's like a Lego
piece it doesn't move you are correct
these guys are a different look at this
[ __ ] strike I'm a human being his
ground impound but the thing with yawn
don't get it twisted yawn the Polish
power if he can defend the takedown
early on it's not a Bad Bet to bet on
yawn via uh KO early on he's a champion
and a [ __ ] giant this whole like
you didn't go back to the international
thing you love that it's like
the thing about young is he's a power
punt he doesn't throw any punch without
power behind yeah no he's like a [ __ ]
Mack truck every punch he's like that's
that's a heavyweight it's supposed to be
Globe Glover now Dana said Glover gets
the next title shot no matter what
because
um Yuri's out because he literally blew
his shoulder out of socket and he's in
Camp and his boys who were in his camper
like oh we'll put it back in oh no they
kept pushing it pushing it and he tore
everything in his shoulder oh no so bad
that the doctor was like this were
children's we've ever seen so he's out
for a hot second that's why he didn't
just this is the way he might be done
because it's trouble look at Johnny
Walker I mean blue you know ruined his
career but he's just not it wasn't like
you it's this is an intern light
heavyweight belt he just vacated the
belt because he's out for a hot second I
bet we don't see him for at least a year
I love that you're using hot in uh on
hot way yeah blowing out your shoulders
yeah not hot dude he's out for a sexy
second yeah oh look at that
yeah he's a nightmare he's a [ __ ] I
think he's the biggest favorite on the
main character really yeah
but it's not again I don't think he's
gonna do it but if you're gonna bet yawn
early on defend the takedown
polish punches
this Main Event man I'm used to roughing
around I think it was seven hours
fun time but so did we ever find out why
the
Glover turned down the yeah he was
because he was getting ready for a year
really a complete Striker he's like on
the short notice I'm against the title
shot for that and then he's gonna get
guaranteed the next foul shot so he's
just gonna take his time it was smart
business move on go overspark you don't
want to switch a completely different
matchup
and they guaranteed him the next title
shot Dana said that on I think Patty's
show
Frankie how are you a kind of courses
what how are your dogs I hate you I hate
dogs your kids love them though huh
remember what do you want to get rid of
the dog and your son goes no that
doesn't work for me they're like well
you got to take care they like the idea
yeah they love big dogs 10 minutes a
night I have two uh Cane Corsos and you
hate them yeah they're great dogs
actually the best yeah that female asked
me about 125 000 oh my God they take
dinosaur shits
I have 11 months or 11 week old puppy
and his shits are like it's like a grown
man just [ __ ] on my grass oh yeah just I
have a pug and it takes monster dad does
yes half its body is [ __ ] pugs have
those curly stupid Tails so their
[ __ ] are in your face all the time
it's like if crystal meth was an answer
I'm gonna send you a picture uh video of
me getting bit by us hey Sam hug huh you
gay man oh dude my pug is gay as [ __ ]
yeah bro those pugs are what a big junk
no it's no just assault my gay friends
by saying your pug is gay my pug is
power German gay wow
why why'd you get with the Pug uh price
long story
long story really yeah
my Cane Corso came yeah it is not cheap
yeah
I bored them it's 250 they're so
expensive a day yeah they're a liability
how big are they what do they look like
they're about 140. if you had a black
one it's literally like you have a
panther Guardian mine really this one's
black female you're female oh I want one
I'm a be obsessed with your female his
female is amazing I like that exactly oh
I want one so bad they're great dogs see
this hand my other one is exactly that
dog yeah that looks like my dog um I got
a fawn one Frank he's a fawn he's a show
dog this thing my big guy's a show dog
why are they bad with my dog if you
don't train them properly and like
socialize them you know they're they're
140 pound animal like he had a mountain
lion
but they're great with kids they're the
best dog
you're like oh yeah it's terrifying yeah
anyone robbing the house I mean your dog
was good with my baby your dog was
protecting my baby they're the the best
animal ever with kids from you that's
why I do I swear to God well he was just
like sitting there with she was the
female was just sitting there with my
baby like just I trust them implicitly
with kids that's what they're born to do
my son is that right grabbed the cane
Corso's face his wiener yeah
the Roman soldiers would leave them with
their kids you look 90 years old enough
right Jesus Christ Jesus Christ I think
you look great thanks buddy I have some
sunglasses on
that look at that [ __ ] dog right
there oh do you think where they attack
you yeah I put them never seen that I
thought we're gonna scare the [ __ ] out
of me man honestly I would never get to
let a Connie Corso bite me never their
jaws are too strong they would crush you
it's just it's 140 pounds you can't have
it you in a bite suit you can't have
that dog bite
oh is this the dog that's a female right
there that's me no that's a male that
come they said that would you could
never have that dog as a pet right now
he's great you could he could he he's
you could never yeah they go you could
never own him as a pet ever okay because
because in two years old he would start
biting people unless you have to train
them yeah it's all about two years old
he's no joke though at two years old
they start turning on training That's
Mike ritlin uh uh
exhausting he only spoke spoke German
you'd like to wear that Robin now watch
this watch this watch this watch watch
this watch this watch this watch this
watch this watch this I'm [ __ ] around
Here Comes Jan by the way
this thing is [ __ ] hating me it's
weird to have a dog hate you
I'm trying to hate what you represent
yeah it ain't your stupid food I got
scared here because she was like she was
having trouble holding it and I was like
okay
I love Michael Jackson 100 your dog
that's a 67 pound dog I'm gonna scared
the [ __ ] out of me
you look like you're the leader of the
fan club yeah Ice Cube you look like you
by the way that's Mighty Morphin Power
Ranger life yeah that's true pretty
anticlimactic video thanks guys thanks
for tuning in guys hey let's watch them
through this main event
runs on real quick before yawn and watch
me stick shake this diet no action no
Brian going oh no no no no no the lady
grabs it
oh that was nothing all right well that
sucked huh that sucks
don't take me down there's no excitement
in there none no no that was hard on
everybody just like saying that name
I've never had a white claw I just like
saying can I have no idea have you had
them no I mean unless you're rushing for
a frat Franklin [ __ ] uh you're a
[ __ ] alcoholic but you like uh I
would drink I'm a wino I'm not an
alcoholic no you like wine yeah I like
rose and uh tequila tequila tequila I'll
drink I only drink Browns the only time
I saw you drink a lot was when you're
both your parents died within a week of
each other yeah
um his mom dies suddenly and then his
dad dies a week later three weeks yeah
a week later yeah broken heart and then
Frank was drinking morning Frank would
drink in the morning he'd be like the
Italians I mean it's food you know I've
never seen that 39 verse 30 here
Brian you want to bet on this one uh yes
I do who you got Monument
but again if you if you're betting on
DraftKings I'm gonna go properly with
this bet and I'm going to shock you with
a first round knockout oh wow Jesus I
like that who are you taking Margaret
that's that's uh that's uh second rule
fight club besides Ben on Robbie Lawler
your con communist uh the second rules
you don't bet against pakistanians or
Russians ever yeah ever but polls are no
joke yeah
who wants it
throw 50 on Mark goodart that dude is
Jack that's a thick kid marketers watch
his hair pay attention to his hair looks
like he just woke up longer than it
normally is yeah it is I'm questioning
that I know he might yeah I don't like
it I don't know man they got a bunch of
Amish over there and he's got a chick
it's interesting dude those dagestanian
bowl cuts oh The Barbers are like yeah
get in here yeah clip clip clip he's
just getting away you're like hey man
I'd like to I'd like it like this can I
get my haircut like this every picture
in the barber shop is the same haircut I
always wondered what the theory behind
not having the mustache grown in as
thick as the beard it looks like his
like his looks sweet I know you're
saying dagger stains that's what they do
hey what's an easier job being a
dagestanian barber or being liver King's
uh chef laughs
[Laughter]
how about a chef how about a chef
uh raw nuts and liver uh coming right up
he's just kicking away with a shot of
steroids I don't believe that's all he's
eating dude I I ate me and Brian ate
those balls in front of him I almost
threw up I saw you you were going oh
dude it was not for me I don't do well
with that stuff it's the tech I'm a
textured guy how tall is he six three
yeah yeah he's built like a middleweight
yeah like he could hang more weight on
himself easily
uh yeah he's got those how tall is Jon
Jones six four six four six five ish
probably six five because guess what six
six so probably about six five do you
think they should get like another
weight class between 205 and heavyweight
it's insane dude because I was a small
heavyweight I'd weigh like 233 sometimes
like you had a diary
that was 265. I'm 233. I'm like what are
we doing here they should have a 225 yes
but there's not you know the athletes
there's not enough they would be Warsaw
post dude if you come from a place where
it starts with the war you're badass and
look at his block head
he's got a pugilistic by the way Warsaw
is the most most famous it's like wants
a high five from Bruce Buffer and he's
not getting it right does it look he's
like hey don't leave me hanging
everybody's watching he's like come on
okay [ __ ] it all that quick I'm gonna
pissed off he did this
at least you're gonna straighten his
fingers out
yeah just yells out he can block [ __ ]
look at this look at this [ __ ]
look at his hair it looks like his own
game hey Sasquatch is alive yeah it's
like someone gave him a noogie before
yeah
I thought he was big and then he went
dude you got Poland versus Russia or
Dagestan also it's the dagestan's time
it's his time this guy is like he's
chomping at the nobody nobody wants this
again isn't it like crazy how we go
through these Cycles where like Brazil
has all the Champions and now now it's
gonna be the Dage now now here's the
thing magma is a much more technical
Striker oh man yes
strike dude yeah I I give John The Edge
you do grappling all day technical
striking or yawn really Mago man's got
crisp striking Bubba
just just look at these dudes what else
hey what other jobs would they do real
men or whatever they want did you guys
wait do you know what's funny about
before you went in no you know what's
funny about Brennan these guys are too
small for him
what do you mean you're like look at
these dudes I'm like hey [ __ ] face
you're 270 pounds and they would be too
small how much you weigh now I'm like
250. I'm not 27. if you had the recipe
if you had to wrestle with both these
guys they'd have their hands full right
now
I think the only thing I have over them
is I have better hair
somebody needs to get fired
what do you mean the the hairstylist for
the dagestani you let your guy go out
there looking like he just got some how
dare you have a hair out of place yeah
for a title fight Yeah by fire do you
mean they're gonna get killed yeah
that's how he counters that's what I'm
saying he's got that he's just [ __ ]
amazing
subtly very different it's the facial
here that would scare me watch his watch
how he controls distance oh that's why
me ask you does that do any protection
nobody like no boxing has that weird
Theory with Kimbo two boxing where you
can have a beard like you can't even
have facial hair in uh amateur boxing
when I did Golden Gloves they came up to
me they thought it was Mexican they gave
me a shaver so I looked 100 Mexican just
had to shave my beard I said it just had
a mustache it's not good I look like the
biggest heavyweight Mexican you've ever
seen
and you are
but I'm 100 Mexican you're 100 Mexican
these guys facial hair dude
yeah I don't know yeah this Young's not
hearing a peep out of this guy for a
reason standing around
that's the problem man they're filling
each other out yeah give them a chance
all right the distance on your boys has
a speed Advantage though magomet's got a
tail piece by the way at certain angles
you're going to see a tailpiece on this
kid yeah Yana has a flat ass right now
it's got a tail piece and magma is a big
[ __ ] natural boy that's natural
dagestani [ __ ] muscle this guy he
lives Among the Stars
nobody's looking at tail pieces this
guy's like well that's your curves to
the right power comes are you looking at
a midlife sexual preference there's a
lot of power because I'm okay with it
there's a lot of power I heard you I
mean wow well I guess my inside voice is
finally coming up
hey B I would say though yeah we're
having that much power I agree with you
like if this is a Brazilian ass contest
our boy magomed wins that first round he
took a shot to that right eye no I'm
saying magoman's got an ass on him and
I'm saying uh Yawn is flat he's flat
he's a Polish flat ass yeah dude he's
got a uh I'm almost 40 ass yeah yeah
dude when you almost four you lose your
ass not me dude except for this guy you
turn 40 unless you're working out like
Frank you turned five you got Mr Burns
ass
[ __ ] pick up Mr Burns I don't know
who went to this school gorilla was
doing Al Pacino impression
impersonations at Al Pacino
like it and no and then he started
[ __ ] challenging a Sherwood Leonard
to a boxing match
Sugar Ray was like wait a minute what
the [ __ ] going on
he
moved to Florida though
he told you that right yeah he's still
here
because he uh he's doing that show Tulsa
King it's fantastic is it good I'm so
good is it I'm Paramount yeah that's the
worst app out there Paramount app is
like logs me out every time
it might be your Wi-Fi because I have it
too I've never been I've never been
logged out of them yeah me neither
it's like uh The Sopranos Yellowstone
had a baby that's how good it is yeah
Sylvester Stallone's fantastic he's the
best he's so stiff he's the best oh yeah
but he's yeah he's got he's great he
needs to do some yoga he did a lot of
his own stunts his body's all broken
yeah that's two rods in his back yeah
there used to be a rumor that he I can't
do it no please do no it's conspiracy
and I don't like gay but he did some
naked stuff right some no yeah oh yeah
for sure I'll get it out of you Sam I
know where I can't say you and I are in
the same I'll say it off air okay
see that's a tough round to score I
think they should be an even round I
don't think because they're forced
because of the scoring they have to give
somebody that round I think that should
be an even round who's round who do you
give it to I guess uh mahmed because he
was going forward you know how are you
going to judge that
why his beards browned his hair's black
Isn't that cool
that is cool that's a rough kid
how old is this guy 30. is he 30 he's 30
years old he's been fighting for a hot
minute yeah that was my girlfriend
Young's 38. you're growing 30.
yeah congratulations Frank I mean you're
30. you know dude you have such a
vulnerable life maybe your wife's house
stop batting yourself my wife's 33. yeah
yeah he's older than his wife's uh dad
uh no no is it weird that 60 or mom's
two years older than me like I said
you're older you're about to sing
it's tough to score I think it should be
a it should be an even round but they
don't do that I don't know I'm riveted
to this fight
are your eyes a gin blue or are they are
they emerald green I can't figure out
what the [ __ ] the Ferrari ocean blue is
that what it is they change they what do
you know what they're like mood rings
they're like oracles
or Orville I don't know
it bro yeah
well when when when it's five rounds
they usually the first round they fool
each other out and then they pick the
pace up so first try until we just toss
up yep
here we go
you never expect these big boys to go
five rounds
my rounds is tough man well as jail son
said no athletic competition be 25
minutes no
so Matthew Wells Paul Fontaine give it
10 oh wow
Ryan Frederick 10-9
I'm not seeing any b-shop tweets no
athletic thing should be 25 minutes
that's what jail says I mean NBA games
are what no that's a team sport though
oh yeah Uncle live Uncle live but tennis
is a hot suck you know yeah too long
though
foreign
who'd you give it to
go most people gave it to magamed on on
the tweets because he's moving forward
I was just catching them a little more
and then one guy gave it to John because
he said he landed more power shots but
it's tough this shouldn't even round
stupid oh that's
just someone's gonna start opening up
here yep but notice how this guy's been
in
seven minutes of a hand fight and his
hair hasn't changed it's alarming it's
actually gotten better yeah that that
it's a weird shark fin he had is
starting to go down
it still looks like you got a Nuggie huh
yeah is it a nugget nugi
but you know what on this one dougie
dougie
maybe in Dagestan they call it Nuggie
that's what see I like to go back to
their ways they're good they're local
Customs yes that's a big boy what yes
they can't hear you brother
I know without periods yeah I think
Margaret made one
um
what food do they eat in Pakistan I'm
sure you've been there goat that makes
sense
I'll be honest with you
the Polish
fight this this round he's winning this
round I think so
Giannis I mean he was World Champ you
know correct World Champ beat a lot of
good guys
including Izzy
uh well there you go headstrike 14 12.
an 11 uh kicks
he just got caught he got caught behind
the ear oh yeah yeah I got caught yeah
God I'd love to see some grappling out
of them
hate when it's just a fight like this do
ya oh I like grappling ow oh he got his
foot ow okay he's backing up
ah oh good cake there oh look Beyonce
and come on
God young young got the tank for a head
man just a blockhead huh both of them
did slug head
what do you think of the the kick to the
knees do you like that like oh
though that that that that [ __ ] my
time and now it's a it's just everybody
that [ __ ] his leg up I agree like to
the kicked it his right leg that [ __ ]
that was before my time now John started
then uh Jon Jones but Jon Jones started
then Jackson started and they all
started doing it and then once you start
really affecting guys now it's just part
of the game
I hate that I don't like it I hate that
and I hate when you go to high five and
they they jump yeah I hate that
sportsmanship yeah I don't like any of
that the the kick to the knee it's like
you're taking out the guy's career man
but then it's also a fist fight so it's
conflicted
you can't take many more of those John's
head though kicking those legs huh
who has a better beard
oh my God no no
um it's more it's more trimmed
the other guy's too busy to be doing
that listen dude where's oh we're
sponsored by manscape on this show we
prefer trim yeah Tam's right
from the waist down code
no he's not
oh that's some magic happen round two
one one yeah I would say I'm on this one
one
it's gonna be a close Fight Man ah
they'll start open up this dirt his legs
compromised uh-oh the way he's walking
yeah both both of his legs compromised
oh his foot's all [ __ ] up oh yeah dude
oh he's one of those guys that doesn't
sit oh I don't see it either dude dagger
stains don't sit I fight any of you
[ __ ] guys I'm not sitting
shout out to my boy Dave Stewart who's
about to have a baby and naming him Remy
Remy yeah they stop your son well uh
yeah I mean they love they love the name
and uh see that kick right there I'm
using this uh platform to announce it
shout it out he's like dude you guys my
buddy uh John Bancorp just had a baby
last night Shout It Out shout it out
what do you name them look at his legs
look at his legs no the way he walked
back to the corner his legs compromise I
don't know if the analysts are talking
about it but definitely compromised
yeah he got they're also pale oh those
are some Russian legs yeah yeah and
those are some hurt legs yeah yeah he's
in trouble with those legs he looks like
he just got his tattoo [ __ ] he can't
believe how much money he owes Jan looks
like he stepped out of [ __ ] now now
the fight starts
in trouble [ __ ] that that'll lose fights
dude now the fight starts because these
boys they felt each other out and now
it's time to get protect that back now
now he sees where he's weak that [ __ ]
that calf oh yeah that leg is
comfortable yeah he's making sure look
he's switching stances he's moving
around he doesn't want to get kicked
that's not good if he moves back he's
got to throw punches yes and he can't
and he can't like push off it
no y'all didn't keep eating it up he
smells it see he's making sure you're
gonna get kicked yeah that's awful
at this point you can't even check the
kicks they still oh keep going your legs
on yeah there you go inside inside God
man yawn found a [ __ ] in the armor yes
he did he found a chicken armor [ __ ] in
the old armor
there's Asians he found out
oh you see that though watch he gets
caught with that he's throwing bombs
here he found a little uh a loose gate
but but it's got a lot more speed in his
hands so see that
yeah but without your legs your your
arms are not very strong yeah you're
gonna push off on a punch oh Giannis is
using this [ __ ] size but John's got to
be careful not to come in too fast and
get a little overzealous yeah we gotta
hope the judges get in touch there look
at that right I'm surprised uh Monument
doesn't shoot more if his legs are
compromised get him out of there man oh
he's coming in also fight closer so he
can't kick him dude there hasn't been a
single double lap Outside Inside the
middle of that gun it's all cage side
grappling
which is weird
yawn chin down focused
come on boys
I'm gonna shoot
buddyman makes him pay dummy yeah his
Magma's nose he's tagging him though now
yeah yeah again look at his hand by the
way his legs don't look compromised
anymore oh he's gotta keep pushing it
because still he can't let him set up to
kick him in the low yeah yeah cause yeah
he can't kick gun going backwards I
think that's his idea there yeah he
should shoot though see how he keeps
throw that front kick you keep him at
Bay that makes sense keep pressing oh
wow ah that one hurt too oh oh that
might be the nerve dad uh he got that
both
boys suck now every single fighter from
here on out the fight tomorrow that's
right watching this film going well now
magman's got a train for this he's got
to start checking kicks right but you
can't see those kicks from me yeah
oh good shot he has a fight in a phone
booth right now to uh stop these guys if
you don't have your legs you don't have
any power oh my God he just hates
getting kicked there well I have power
because if I get my legs Brian stop stop
holy ghost power
that's all I'm trying to say
yeah my much rather be here than the
outskirts getting kicked in the legs yep
you gotta hope the judges score the leg
kicks though that's why you never see me
it's the biggest Damage Done in the
fight for sure
because this is nothing
although it's octagon control but still
good elbow there yep stay back oh yeah
there you go no God he's getting in
tight and Jan's not having it no John's
not having well if you told me Yan was
gonna
freaking dominate on takedown defense I
would have told you John wins this fight
yeah I'm saying hey John is winning this
fight yeah in my humble opinion yep
and that's why now that it went from
sitting outside striking the the closing
distance because his legs are
compromised well I'm losing look at that
front leg it's planted and it's right in
front of him again
he's gonna get kicked again hey can't
like you can't let him set up a kick
he's got to buy some time to let these
buddy
here we go oh man that was slow
shooting he's bending down here
polish wiener shot oh dude Polish
sausage shot is that legal
weiner shots weiner shots are not legal
they used to let that weiner shot slide
look at that that's gotta suck
oh no it's actually nice because
especially sometimes that cup protects
it gives you a nice five minute rest of
room yeah because also that was a little
bit nobody takes a five I would take it
down I would I'd have the whole Arena I
think you would the pressure from the
crowd you're like I better get back in
oh really yeah take that and the ref
keeps going you okay you ready to go
you're like hey hey hey hey be cool let
me just send this email room exhausted
this is a hell of a fight guys it really
is [ __ ] hey man are you kidding man
he doesn't have a prince he's not
shooting he's just like bending over
yeah he's bending over then John's just
lifting him up he doesn't mind you on a
sprawl on him he's not going down to the
legs to get the thighs he's just
shooting mid body
it's interesting I feel like that ref's
too close I guess he's looking for
wiener shots
look how focused he is on the wiener
he's kind of like Brian Carroll he's
like Brian Campbell
oh is that a headbutt no no wow
that was a take so the question how much
is that gives us no time dude
who's that guy with the hair in the
audience
what a tough look at this hair doesn't
move doesn't move done move done move
don't move stunning now it's done moving
fantastic
but there's it's just that fake man it's
like dude
that's a natural butterfly if I'm like a
Pomade Hair Company I'm sponsoring all
day yeah for sure look their hair
doesn't move during five rounds of the
championship fighting I say things in
the air dude would you say B I get it I
say things in the air sometimes
these guys are sweating yeah yeah these
guys are sweating now these guys have
tight shorts
these guys are boom
missed again missed again uh the kick
was all right
oh [ __ ]
and that's right oh man
okay oh [ __ ] running that one to me John
won that round that's the most I think
Damage Done unless you give that take
down I have it 2-1 for y'all me too oh
Jesus Christ look at this who's I don't
know whose legs those are what are those
are they're both white what a way to
make a living yeah please scroll up and
see how he gets him real close he
because he can't let him kick that leg
round four kids this is a god fight now
fight no just fight yeah
yeah I'm wants that
come on
he's just not throwing the the
there it is
man shooting high in here shooting I
know here his legs must be super
compromised that he can't like get any
kind of burst that's a good point he's
not bending down I think we've abused
the word compromised I I did I think I
said it once I might have said it three
times you said it three times they
compromise a lot yeah I like to keep
kicking legs I say compromise I like
compromise I like kids
your legs are compromised have we used
it out too many compromised I think
we're abusing it I think the words I
like this better
your legs are getting gimped I like that
I don't like that that makes me nauseous
now where I come from we go bro you're
getting your legs camped no I don't like
that yeah you remind me of that I'm back
to compromised yeah in Silence of the
slams in the in the in the Greenwich
Connecticut when we used to have this
pit fighting thing no uh gimps from Pulp
Fiction that's right no but yeah bring
out the [ __ ] bring out the game dead but
remember who is the guy who was sowing
the body and and silences
Buffalo Bill did a movie with him he's
awesome yeah yeah it puts the lotion on
the skin
precious where are you precious oh
there's the [ __ ] I just saw that you
actually played the [ __ ]
is he a famous actor football you don't
know John the two seconds are you being
serious no that's who played the game
bro
hey man you're spreading rumors about
John matusek I think um I think mutusack
fell out
ain't that a [ __ ] you're a gampp and
one of the most famous movies of all
time your face is never shown yeah I'm
too sack come on you knew him at two
seconds oh yeah he was crazy not the
[ __ ] though right too big to be done
look he's a big stuff the game was a
smaller guys are we watching this we got
we got it taken down yeah I gotta take
him down
which if he holds him here
yeah
yeah hey you guys
[ __ ] loves junk yeah shitty roll no one
no one knows you walk on the street no
one knows you're it doesn't matter but
that's iconic you want your face Frank I
did one movie they had a mascot here we
go I kept taking the mask off they go
cut hey dude extra crazy right now I'm
tired yeah this is bad very young yeah
this is not good
it's that weight
then you got a wolf man yelling at you
oh wow look at that guy he's best here
of the night though yeah well that guy
he looks like that you gotta hold him
down you gotta hold him down
the whole squad's just never gonna lose
their hair there's definitely a medieval
look they all look like a different
version of the same guy yes yes they do
like different yeah they all look like
they're on a different part of the
timeline like the one in the back looked
like the 16 year old version 22 year old
version yeah
install go the same bar have you ever
heard what kind of Jiu Jitsu does he
have
these are this is like zombies no no but
it's just heavy on top he's not like no
the uh yawn yeah not great off his back
no no polish
right yeah oh yeah he's getting him back
for getting kicked in the leg yeah he's
like I kicked my leg Yeah oh he's got
him locked up hey I like to keep it real
and uh not the best fight I've ever seen
okay really now I love this fight
who's the black belt Chin Young
under black belt and Jitsu Camille it's
not a real one ski and radar Turk okay
where'd he get his black belt from from
Camille oh um
I don't know exactly if you don't have a
Brazilian last name I usually don't
enjoy it I think uh it's 2-2
going into this final
round if he makes it out of this round
yeah this guy's a nightmare that's what
Margaret does he just beats the [ __ ] up
there's I think Brad Moreno's done by
the way getting getting on down like
this and doing this to him yeah gives
you an idea [ __ ] he's about big deal
Brian a big deal Brendan
keeping his head in his forehead right
in this [ __ ] right next to the guys
oh oh that's what he does best
just beat you up straight kick to that
and then kick your ass
yeah good job bro that's that Russian
big toe to the ass it looks like me and
my brother fighting
hey B do you like that nickname for you
if you're a fighter big deal Brian the
big deal Carolyn
I thought it was totally [ __ ] I
thought you were agree with that one
[ __ ]
Brian this guy never gets old Kelly he
nicknamed yourself the kid though huh
yeah I did right I gave myself that
nickname I appreciate it for years I
thought you got that I can't get Sat one
day and I go from now on guys please
refer to me as the kid and they were
like okay kid I go no no I'm sorry it's
the kid when I first met Brian we're
doing the he's like let's do a podcast
guy I'm like we're gonna call you to
find the kid you're the fighter I'm the
kid I'm like who calls you the kitties
everybody they said give me the name on
stage I'm like
that makes sense and then years went by
and went hold on hold on
and here we are here we go final ride 15
years later that's right buddy
still a kid
so that yeah they have it 38 38
that's what it says yep well this uh uh
John Morgan has it 38 38 too
38 38.
this is a hell of a fight man oh [ __ ]
get up get up yeah
what is going on chaos that's just is
the worst thing that could happen to you
is that ghost he's a black belt I don't
believe oh let's see what he does oh
look at that
them dagus standings don't play that leg
Yeah they don't care about you Jitsu
they don't much care yeah well [ __ ] is
a great you remember that I'm sure let
them out what was the shirt shirt that
could be more if I if [ __ ] was easy
it'd be called Jujitsu yeah yeah
dude come on man
well you don't want the fifth round like
this yeah well you do if you're you're a
dad yeah yeah hey Chen is he actually
from dakistan I almost went to Dagestan
for fight world that was the first place
I was going run what happened I think
the president decided he was going to
lock up uh no that was chechnya no it
was Dagestan Dexter don't play those
games either B yeah
yeah my man is Russian professional or
okay nothing about Alexander from
Russia
live education dagus stands
trying to describe where he was educated
go ahead and read that fellas go ahead
and do something
dude
oh he's a Greco wrestler do you see a
hat
I like it how about I was in uh
Starbucks before this and this guy comes
up to me and goes hey do I know who you
are I'm like I have no idea doing this
and he goes you know I am right I go I
have no older guy I have no idea he goes
come on man you come on the memory guy
I'm sorry oh you're young I'm the memory
guy I have the world record for best
memory and two movies come on dude on oh
yeah yeah the memory guy he's an older
guy so I'm trying to well will you look
up the memory guy so we can see who
please bring him up couldn't remember
dude please bring him up and then he
goes and I'm saying line and comes back
and look at this brings up on YouTube
brings up the video of him setting the
world record for the memory they gave
him 50 numbers and they read to him once
and remembered it that's incredible so
he hands me a business card and he goes
don't go anywhere I'm gonna get your
assigned poster I'm like for sure are
you kidding me he goes Brendan right and
I told him how to spell it before you
remembered that and then he goes did I
give you a business card and then I go
I'll tell you a good memory you forget
to give me business cardios don't be a
smart-ass
memory guys asking if is that the memory
guy right there Jim handy or no I have
hey guys well he gave me the sign the
sign posters on the computer over there
okay oh is that him right there the old
guy with the bad hair I think no type in
world record memory holder he's the
memory guy yeah come on everyone knows
who this is this is it I mean this guy
won like yeah you're gonna stop it
you know what oh there he is
there he is yeah that guy who apparently
he's not on the record anymore world
record memory holder they're mostly like
Indian yeah scroll down maybe this guy
was full of [ __ ] he was trying to sell
me
I want to buy some nfts bro hey man I
get a memory
and then he goes come on man you you
never see my movie or comic books I go
uh man maybe I have
I don't remember yeah I don't remember
also I don't care
oh man it's not this guy yeah
that's 100 the guy he's talking about
no it wasn't the no it's that guy
I'm watching this I've seen all this
dude are you guys watching yeah but I'm
just stuck on my job
oh my God
because I I can't did I give you a
business card I go I used the best
memory I remember your business cardios
don't be a smart ass
that was like have a good day John lost
was fine this poster just got wet in the
rain he might lose his life oh he lost
his fight yeah
it's just getting involved getting
mauled on the ground yeah he did two
movies he says he owns a uh a movie
studio he wants to be in his memory
movie three but he said I said I don't
know if you know my memory my man but
what's up what do you do if you're young
just take a beating
that's him dude look he's sci-fi yep
that's the Indian guy first of all he's
not even there it's a bunch of women
no there's a and I don't know why the
the dead act or the dead singers I just
wanted you to beg his wife
hey go to memoryman.com
hold on you guys never seen memory and
the movie or memory man the comic book
this guy this amazing website that's him
that's the guy now picture him age 30
years oh he's incredible and his cell
phone was cracked Batman can memorize a
number like this
he sent me a video I go it shows me
setting the record and it shows him
setting the record and I go that was a
long time ago huh is your memory how's
your memory now goes three times as fast
dude go over to shares 43 and he's gonna
fight this guy otherwise he's asking for
money so if you want a two-year Supply
it's a hundred dollars a year Supply
300. your supply of what
um
that's a great thing I this website's so
old all I gotta say bro if you got a
Yahoo account you're shady as [ __ ] hey
if you got a Discover card on you wait
go back up his stock is for sale no no
no go go down go down go down
memories man stock to be sold
amazing you can buy attention quality
you got to be qualified though he's a
little qualified investors only yeah and
then he goes I gave you my business card
text me
okay David I think he's trying to put me
a sex trafficking to me what yeah I
think he wants you to bang his wife
while he watches yeah speak to memory
man personally because I'm memory man
you can be Memory boy I go so I have CT
I don't think I qualified uh let me see
what he looks like this this genius what
was that him he did set the record yours
sincerely oh boy look at the picture
that's him if you ever say what his real
name is
yeah Dave you know what I feel like I
feel you guys are generally you don't
get the sign poster we can't play it
though yeah we don't want to play I
would love to see it
what would your what's his thing what
would your life be like tomorrow if you
tripled your memory bad [ __ ] that
happened memory man memory memory man
memory improvement pills today place
your order now maybe you can't imagine a
time in the future when you're can we
call him real quick uh why do I need my
memory to be better I know yeah it's
stupid right for lines I say I say what
I feel so memory man use the same also
don't call yourself memory man memory
man use the same ingredients in memory
RAM pill to set the world record on CNBC
he goes his show me those 40 million
people watch this I go really on CNBC oh
yeah all-time record wow it has been
broken on on Margaret I guess Patty went
bad on Ariel they hate it huh yes their
name Jesus what happened
he went bad when I'm in the interview
when when Dana so did Dana
on Ariel no I'm saying just now I'm
winning all right kept talking [ __ ] yeah
Monument has a broken eye socket yeah
according to who
Tom
everybody said that though it's the only
way you'd know if he said that
I assume uh monkey Med won this fight
yeah I mean decision
oh [ __ ] but that should be draws like
this yeah I like draws more I do too
there's no way there's a draw bro look
look at him he went no no it's not
dropped no that's a it's a Draw buddy
wow I don't think that was a draw I
didn't pay enough attention to it so
that sucks well what what do we think
here I mean he just beat the [ __ ] he
beat the [ __ ] out of him how is that a
drug strange
all the same haircut except for the guy
I lost his hair only daggy standing in
Russia without any hair look at him
too right there he's like got a second
so similar
they've all got that beard
we're not allowed to hear this right no
uh but uh tall George is listen yeah the
team's list oh George what's he saying
dude that was bad yeah
manga that should have won
he says he doesn't think he lost the
fight
well so she's not gonna say yeah he won
the fight so the only thing you could do
is like where does that first round go
where you said they were feeling each
other out right because that was that
was the only one that was questionable
for young
and now if I'm yawn I would say I didn't
lose a fight either because I want to
have a chance to fight for a title and
here's who it [ __ ] over global takes
here because he was supposed to
guarantee title shot now they have to
run this back you can't probably do it
for especially if his orbital's broke
who knows man so glower and he's 38 so
you're not he's not fighting for at
least you know six seven months at least
probably longer probably out a year if
you're Clover so you have to take
another fight if you want to get paid so
[ __ ] over Global Tech Sierra he's 44. I
said 38. memory man send me your pills
I want to donate to your sponsi scheme
I wonder what Monument's gonna stay here
they don't look too fast for lunch
yeah dude I mean the only questionable
round is that first round I felt like
these guys each one the other one's
pretty clear right and then most experts
like Kevin aioli's won the best in the
best he had a 2-2 that fifth round was
clear as oh my God I mean it's almost a
10-8 Mega Man yeah all day
it's weird huh well Frank welcome your
first fight companion buddy sorry was it
more excited my last no we'd love to
have it
oh here comes John fight
what do you say what do you say
oh wow
well it doesn't work like that though
it says a lot though it's honorable be
like just give him he's like John's an
honorable man yeah
I told George is on it huh
you want that the memory man pills
I wonder if you if you take that would
you fail a drug test for UFC no it's not
right it's probably meth he just gives
you math to help your memory faster
here we go look at this it's just it's
just micro dosing shrooms
hey memory man these are drugs yeah
they're legal now buddy
I mean what you invest in his business
yeah call me
because I got the perfect leading man
his name's Frank gorilla Brian I'm ready
to go man
I says on Netflix he went no it's just
on my website you have a fun time so you
can get better reviews than you're
special
oh speaking of specials man tears and by
the way if you like stand up come this
this man you're still promoting man dude
yeah man this I know I just dropped it I
just dropped it I always say you just
dropped it and then New Year's Eve guys
live Boston come get something oh
congratulations buddy that's awesome to
hear Sammy uh I have a comedy store on
um one comedy chaos this Wednesday right
yeah next month I'm going to be out
almost a mile a lot just go sanford.com
you're in Illinois
the Russian part about it yeah
Bakersfield at the end and in Long Beach
too I haven't put those dates up
there's some dates out there for 2023
I'm taking the rest of 2022 off yeah
dude it's fun I'm tired come in I need
some breaks I need a break like Margaret
needs a break right now
this is the longest post flight
interview this is like so and so I was
in kindergarten and I knew
so all started when I met memory man and
uh
you can plug in this guy's website's
gonna go hey what I know nephew the
sport posters right now he's at home
going dude why is Amy Winehouse
look at that face he's like I'm gonna go
home now this poster was so confusing
he's so he's getting angry he's getting
angrier these have rough guys man look
at himself guy too
oh look at the guy in the back with the
without the cool hair yeah yeah I got I
got green dude he got robbed yeah I
agree
that might be one of the worst calls
I've seen that's where I say wrong oh
wow his hair's [ __ ] up because he's
grabbing like he's so crazy he's so
great he's crying he was like I mean
dude think about where this dude's from
now it's time what he does for like this
is all his life is and like he literally
won the fight yeah but hey hey class
half full you get to run it back dude
see at the end of the world more money
and now your hair looks like Rick and
Morty the more he lives for now he looks
like the professor from Rick and Morty
he only Bears he had to fight in the
wild to get this shot we're gonna have
to fight a few more and hopefully those
Bears don't like kick it's not it's not
easy he's very emotional right now isn't
it yeah I thought he's gonna win I've
never seen the dagger stand in Christ me
either
because he's cried after he beat Justin
18. who didn't his father yeah I like
you said gaychy there you think Justin
Gage no it's okay she no it's gagey I
know look at this these are the round
breakdowns
oh so everyone gave you on the first
round wow most people gave John the
first three rounds
so interesting yeah that's very well
they're all over the board that's the
problem with the judging
oh dude look at that a 10-8
ten eight weird oh the fifth right I
said it could have been coming today wow
ten that's what [ __ ] them the 10-8
no well if he didn't get 10A he would
have lost the the uh yeah he lost the
fight yeah wow they would give it to
yawn if it wasn't for that there's two
ten eighths it's good it's fine then I
don't mind oh there's two ten eight holy
[ __ ] good eye
wow dude I can't believe everyone
man I can't believe everyone gave uh
yeah on that first round because I
thought well it could go either way but
the fact that all three of them did it
yeah that's interesting
damn and then the 10 a.m
he dominated him I mean
I'm more online with uh Mike Bell there
I don't think there was any 10-8s I I
like the the Mike Bell's scorecard
better
someone needs to check there clearly so
I mean
according to that
I mean they they thought I mean for me
the judges thought that Jans was doing
much better in that fight and it took a
10-8 in for two of the judges in the
last round for it to be a time that's
very strange
I didn't see that at all we also thought
Patty lost the fight but you thought
they were gonna give it to Patty I'm not
saying Patty lost that fight it just it
was a tough fight I'd have to re-watch
it that's to draw The Paddy fights that
was certainly more I thought that was
more acceptable as a drug
interesting significant I mean come on
man come on dude and when he took a zero
zero fights and dude Dion's a great
fighter it's not against him he did the
best he can but you have zero
significant strikes in the last two
rounds no he he really put it on that
fourth and fifth round but look at that
look at the difference in strikes
um Malcolm at one yeah that's part of
the game very strange but the history
books will say it's a dream do you know
that magerman and devastating means
memory man I knew that I didn't know
that yeah
means memory and yeah
memory man it's unbelievable I don't
think so no no you don't no because I
stand on fluid I studied at Kung Fu I
might stop taking Alpha Brain see what
this memory ran gives me yeah man you
should just just give this guy a shot as
a sponsor free sponsor changes life oh
he's the that website's current that's
the great it's the best poster I've ever
seen in my life dude this guy looks like
he was in some MK Ultra [ __ ] right yeah
yeah I just put why is this guy Axiom
seriously if you don't think this guy
believes in Flat Earth you're out of
your mind dude this guy looks like he he
shot drazzle Flip or drazzle shot JFK
look at this poster dude look at and
then why is he this is from the 70s yeah
but who's the guy in The Mask
well first of all that
that's that's memory man that's a cop
drazzle flip is how it's called drazzles
I think that's all from his Comics like
his memory man he saves everybody oh
that's it he's memory man into bondage
that's his superpower BDSM signed to
your butt plugs
dude you should dude I'm afraid that
needs to be framed and put somewhere you
should move that Joe Rogan one and put
that right above the rain sign yeah for
sure for sure dude how jelly are you
right now
you're a jelly monster I'm getting that
as a tattoo what the how long does it
take you to drive home by the way Brian
one hour one hour but I take a chopper
because I make money he does Uber
Chopper yeah
did you drive here or did you take a
helicopter dude you fly so I have a
driver you have a driver dude the level
he's at congratulations on everything
well if he's just attractive modest man
you have chains who gives you those guys
I gotta get going I gotta meet memory
man all right this has been wonderful
damn tripoli.com
on everything I wish you all uh
continued success thank you we love you
we need you out fighter and the kid when
are you gonna promote whatever you want
you come on you don't need to promote
anything just come on as a friend there
you go all right we love you guys that's
it peace out